Hi, I'm Livia Wild.
I somehow got talked into being on Smartless.
So, I don't know.
This is a disaster.
Welcome to Smartless.
We love the eagle.
We la de eel.
Can you get a small, I love you, you get a nice small mustache and then start doing the,
Hi, I'm Livia Wild. I somehow got talked into being on Smartless. So, I don't know. This is a disaster. Welcome to Smartless. We love the eagle. We la de eel. Can you get a small, I love you, you get a nice small mustache and then start doing the,
We lave the only.
And I don't go full, like a little pointy goat.
Yeah, like, um.
We lie.
We love you.
What bella.
What a bella.
We lave the only. And I don't go full, like a little pointy goat. Yeah, like, um. We lie. We love you. We love you. What bella. What a bella.
So, Sean, are those new specs?
Oh, yeah.
Do you like them?
Yeah.
Nope.
No, sorry.
I do.
So, Sean, are those new specs? Oh, yeah. Do you like them? Yeah. Nope. No, sorry. I do. I do.
I'm sorry.
You said that so quickly.
No, I do.
Yeah, look.
I do.
I like them.
They're nice.
I do. I'm sorry. You said that so quickly. No, I do. Yeah, look. I do. I like them. They're nice.
Wait, who made the clear horn rim frames famous?
I feel like it was like a Ted McGinley or one of those handsome fellows.
You're welcome. I think I did.
Andy Richter.
Oh, Andy Richter wears them.
Andy's always worn them. Yeah, for a long time.
What did I just see Andy Richter is in?
He's an obsession.
Wait, who made the clear horn rim frames famous? I feel like it was like a Ted McGinley or one of those handsome fellows. You're welcome. I think I did. Andy Richter. Oh, Andy Richter wears them. Andy's always worn them. Yeah, for a long time. What did I just see Andy Richter is in? He's an obsession.
Obsession, yes.
Yeah, he was great.
I love Andy.
Can I just say that just as a general rule?
We all do.
I know.
What's not to love?
He's so fucking funny.
Obsession, yes. Yeah, he was great. I love Andy. Can I just say that just as a general rule? We all do. I know. What's not to love? He's so fucking funny.
Yeah, he is funny.
Well, they can take the surprise out of your voice.
No, I'm not surprised, but you have those moments where you just think about somebody.
You go, God, Andy, God, we used to have so much remember, we used to play cards
with Andy.
See, he's still alive.
Yeah.
No, I know.
Yeah, he is funny. Well, they can take the surprise out of your voice. No, I'm not surprised, but you have those moments where you just think about somebody. You go, God, Andy, God, we used to have so much remember, we used to play cards with Andy. See, he's still alive. Yeah. No, I know.
I'm just saying, remember
we used to play cards
all the time back in the day.
I know, with Kyle Bass.
You know, with Kyle.
I remember Andy one time
at my old place in Venice.
Remember when he came down the stairs
I'm just saying, remember we used to play cards all the time back in the day. I know, with Kyle Bass. You know, with Kyle. I remember Andy one time at my old place in Venice. Remember when he came down the stairs
and he had,
so many, Giles had brought
like fudge or something
and Andy came down and he had,
and there was fudge all around his mouth.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
And he's like, hey, I couldn't find the fudge.
and he had, so many, Giles had brought like fudge or something and Andy came down and he had, and there was fudge all around his mouth. Yeah. Uh-oh. And he's like, hey, I couldn't find the fudge.
I couldn't find the fudge.
And it was all.
around his mouth. He was like, it wasn't anywhere. I couldn't find it anywhere. Yeah. Jay, what did you think
about obsession? Wasn't it in a good movie? Yeah, I really liked it. Now, is that what you were watching
with my wife the other day? I was watching it with your wife in your house and you weren't there.
I was just jealous. Yeah. Oh, let me just check my phone. Scotty was there too. And Scotty was there,
yeah. Let me just see. You're going to pay for that. I know. You will pay for that one. I will pay for that.
I couldn't find the fudge. I couldn't find the fudge. And it was all. around his mouth. He was like, it wasn't anywhere. I couldn't find it anywhere. Yeah. Jay, what did you think about obsession? Wasn't it in a good movie? Yeah, I really liked it. Now, is that what you were watching with my wife the other day? I was watching it with your wife in your house and you weren't there. I was just jealous. Yeah. Oh, let me just check my phone. Scotty was there too. And Scotty was there, yeah. Let me just see. You're going to pay for that. I know. You will pay for that one. I will pay for that.
I will pay for that one. No. You're going to text the guys after this session. You're going to say, hey, guys,
Did you trim out the little spot
where I totally forgot
that Scott was sitting next to me?
Wait, Jason, you just nodded to somebody.
Is that somebody making you an egg sandwich or something?
Ew.
Very close.
I will pay for that one. No. You're going to text the guys after this session. You're going to say, hey, guys, Did you trim out the little spot where I totally forgot that Scott was sitting next to me? Wait, Jason, you just nodded to somebody. Is that somebody making you an egg sandwich or something? Ew. Very close.
Oh, ew.
Who's there?
Thanks, Morgan.
Who's Morgan?
Morgan is my incredible partner here in...
JP?
Oh, you've got a partner now.
Look at you.
Oh, ew. Who's there? Thanks, Morgan. Who's Morgan? Morgan is my incredible partner here in... JP? Oh, you've got a partner now. Look at you.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's...
Now, I have two partners here.
I don't like to say assistance.
Yeah, good for you.
Because I like to stay relatable.
Yeah, sure.
But you know who is assisting my assistant here?
Yeah. Yeah, she's... Now, I have two partners here. I don't like to say assistance. Yeah, good for you. Because I like to stay relatable. Yeah, sure. But you know who is assisting my assistant here?
Who's that?
Frannie.
Francesca Nora Bateman.
Is she there right now?
She is.
Oh, tell her we say hello.
Want to see her?
Yeah, I'll turn.
Who's that? Frannie. Francesca Nora Bateman. Is she there right now? She is. Oh, tell her we say hello. Want to see her? Yeah, I'll turn.
Yeah, let's hear the camera.
There she is out there in the production office.
Can he see her?
Oh yeah, look at that.
Look at her.
You're just in some lonely office.
You know, by the way, you know who stays relatable?
Yeah, let's hear the camera. There she is out there in the production office. Can he see her? Oh yeah, look at that. Oh yeah, look at that. Look at her. You're just in some lonely office. You know, by the way, you know who stays relatable?
Mm.
People who don't say, I want to stay relatable.
Yeah.
Because they don't have to curate it.
My insincerity is bleeding through.
Yeah, man.
What is the sandwich that you got, though?
Are you going to dig into it?
Mm. People who don't say, I want to stay relatable. Yeah. Because they don't have to curate it. My insincerity is bleeding through. Yeah, man. What is the sandwich that you got, though? Are you going to dig into it?
I don't know.
We just push forward.
We don't talk about your net jets or...
Let's go past that.
We'll go past that.
Let's talk about that.
Or your Long Island second home.
God.
I don't know. We just push forward. We don't talk about your net jets or... Let's go past that. We'll go past that. Let's talk about that. Or your Long Island second home. God.
Let's talk about Nuggets.
There's Scotty.
Oh, look at Scotty.
Don't try to make up for it now, Sean.
Oh, Scott.
He's doing prey hands.
By the way, it's easy travel.
You know, you call and then they're there
Let's talk about Nuggets. There's Scotty. Oh, look at Scotty. Don't try to make up for it now, Sean. Oh, Scott. He's doing prey hands. By the way, it's easy travel. You know, you call and then they're there
and then they get you from where you need to go.
It's notches.
You should try.
Try one flight.
Not a paid ad. One flight's a better service.
Not a paid ad.
NJets.
This is disgusting.
and then they get you from where you need to go. It's notches. You should try. Try one flight. Not a paid ad. One flight's a better service. Not a paid ad. NJets. This is disgusting.
It's so gross, guys.
Let's not cut it, though.
So, Sean, now, Sean, what did Scotty bring you?
Is that just a bowl of mixed Pop-Tarts?
No.
It's warm milk.
It's tea.
It's tea with sugar and cream.
It's so gross, guys. Let's not cut it, though. So, Sean, now, Sean, what did Scotty bring you? Is that just a bowl of mixed Pop-Tarts? No. It's warm milk. It's tea. It's tea with sugar and cream.
Sugar and cream.
What kind of, even with the tea, you can't take your foot off the gas.
I think it's artificial sweetener today.
What kind of tea are we having?
Just regular English breakfast tea.
You know, there's a cake lady coming, though.
Remember the cake lady?
Well, this is not a surprise.
Sugar and cream. What kind of, even with the tea, you can't take your foot off the gas. I think it's artificial sweetener today. What kind of tea are we having? Just regular English breakfast tea. You know, there's a cake lady coming, though. Remember the cake lady? Well, this is not a surprise.
Yeah, but yes, I do remember.
Yeah, the cake.
So, Jay...
I don't remember.
What do you mean cake?
He's got a woman who...
I've used her.
She's amazing.
Yeah, but yes, I do remember. Yeah, the cake. So, Jay... I don't remember. What do you mean cake? He's got a woman who... I've used her. She's amazing.
She's great.
And she'll make any cake you want.
What are you talking about?
For one of the kids' birthdays.
Yeah, she's...
We call her...
Her name is Cake Lady, but she's a real name.
Well, let's pull the relatable bus.
She's great. And she'll make any cake you want. What are you talking about? For one of the kids' birthdays. Yeah, she's... We call her... Her name is Cake Lady, but she's a real name. Well, let's pull the relatable bus.
over to the side for a second.
No, she's like 10 bucks a cake.
You don't go down to the fucking store and buy a cake?
No, she's like 10 bucks and she delivers it.
Yeah.
She makes it and she'll deliver it to your house
and it's the best case I've ever had.
Because it's such a drag to go to a store
over to the side for a second. No, she's like 10 bucks a cake. You don't go down to the fucking store and buy a cake? No, she's like 10 bucks and she delivers it. Yeah. She makes it and she'll deliver it to your house and it's the best case I've ever had. Because it's such a drag to go to a store
and put some time in to buy your child.
By the way, if anybody gets a siding of J.B. at a store,
please take a pick.
Please.
Step a pick of J.B.
And post it.
Let me tell you.
Went to Whole Foods down a camera.
and put some time in to buy your child. By the way, if anybody gets a siding of J.B. at a store, please take a pick. Please. Step a pick of J.B. And post it. Let me tell you. Went to Whole Foods down a camera.
There are few things that I like better
than pushing
a cart, aisle by aisle by aisle, and taking about three hours to do ten minutes of shopping.
Filed under the heading of things that never fucking happened.
I do love a good market session.
When was the last time?
I mean, last time I was in, actually, what, two days ago.
I had to run down the street to get me and my assistant's assistant some dinner.
There are few things that I like better than pushing a cart, aisle by aisle by aisle, and taking about three hours to do ten minutes of shopping. Filed under the heading of things that never fucking happened. I do love a good market session. When was the last time? I mean, last time I was in, actually, what, two days ago. I had to run down the street to get me and my assistant's assistant some dinner.
Do you go to Whole Foods?
No, I went to this
No, this place that is...
Oh, I know that upscale marketplace.
Yeah, Meadow Lane, right?
That's a...
Yeah, Metal Lane.
By the way, that place, you would talk about relatable.
Do you go to Whole Foods? No, I went to this No, this place that is... Oh, I know that upscale marketplace. Yeah, Meadow Lane, right? That's a... Yeah, Metal Lane. By the way, that place, you would talk about relatable.
That's like the most expensive market in Triton.
But it's so convenient.
It's just down the way.
And it's so nice, it's so aesthetically...
What's it called?
It's called Meadow Lane.
It's sort of...
Sean...
That's like the most expensive market in Triton. But it's so convenient. It's just down the way. And it's so nice, it's so aesthetically... What's it called? It's called Meadow Lane. It's sort of... Sean...
It's the rich man's air one.
It's like...
Which is redundant.
It's very small, but it's incredible.
It's nice.
I don't mean to disparage the place.
It's very nice.
I know, but they've got to come down on prices.
It's the rich man's air one. It's like... Which is redundant. It's very small, but it's incredible. It's nice. I don't mean to disparage the place. It's very nice. I know, but they've got to come down on prices.
It's going to go out of business.
You can't charge $25 for a prepackaged chicken, Chinese, whatever salad thing.
Wait, do you know what Airwan backwards is?
Yeah, man.
Nowhere?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Okay, our next guest, guys, today's guest.
It's going to go out of business. You can't charge $25 for a prepackaged chicken, Chinese, whatever salad thing. Wait, do you know what Airwan backwards is? Yeah, man. Nowhere? Yeah. Thanks. Okay, our next guest, guys, today's guest.
Hey, if you fold a dollar bill into three things, then you'll be able to do.
see that there's a message.
You know what?
More Park is backwards.
More Park, you know the street in the valley?
Sure.
Yeah.
We tell me.
Hey, if you fold a dollar bill into three things, then you'll be able to do. see that there's a message. You know what? More Park is backwards. More Park, you know the street in the valley? Sure. Yeah. We tell me.
It's crap room.
Crapp room.
Wow.
My 14-year-old's going to love that.
Right?
Because she goes to school in there.
Okay.
Thanks for bringing us down.
It's crap room. Crapp room. Wow. My 14-year-old's going to love that. Right? Because she goes to school in there. Okay. Thanks for bringing us down.
Guys, sitting and chatting with us
today is pure sunshine on feet.
This actor-director is a woman I have had the deep
pleasure of working with twice.
Wow.
As an actor, she has done fantastic work in both comedy and drama in film, stage, and TV.
As a director, she's one of the most exciting and sought after new voices today.
And having already done three films, which no doubt there will be more, as many more, as she wants as she wishes.
Guys, sitting and chatting with us today is pure sunshine on feet. This actor-director is a woman I have had the deep pleasure of working with twice. Wow. As an actor, she has done fantastic work in both comedy and drama in film, stage, and TV. As a director, she's one of the most exciting and sought after new voices today. And having already done three films, which no doubt there will be more, as many more, as she wants as she wishes.
She's a true friend.
Olivia Wild.
Reveal yourself, Olivia.
And today, your tasty ear meal here.
Will is Olivia Wild.
How in the world did you get that, Will?
Will.
Will, how did you get that?
She's a true friend. Olivia Wild. Reveal yourself, Olivia. And today, your tasty ear meal here. Will is Olivia Wild. How in the world did you get that, Will? Will. Will, how did you get that?
Because she's one of the most sought after director is out.
Oh, of course.
Come on, of course.
That's an easy.
It's a layup.
I think you could hear my heavy breathing.
I think that's the...
Was that your small dog?
Because she's one of the most sought after director is out. Oh, of course. Come on, of course. That's an easy. It's a layup. I think you could hear my heavy breathing. I think that's the... Was that your small dog?
That was the last part of the intro, Jason.
It says that her heavy...
Known for her heavy breathing, right?
Wild.
Olivia, welcome to the show.
This is great.
I feel like it's long overdue.
Can we have trouble making your deal?
That was the last part of the intro, Jason. It says that her heavy... Known for her heavy breathing, right? Wild. Olivia, welcome to the show. This is great. I feel like it's long overdue. Can we have trouble making your deal?
God, is this overdue.
What?
Well, I, everyone, I finally did every other podcast, and this was in it.
Oh.
No.
You saved the best for last in this world, right?
This is so exciting.
Sitting here spying on you guys is a really weird, thrilling feeling.
God, is this overdue. What? Well, I, everyone, I finally did every other podcast, and this was in it. Oh. No. You saved the best for last in this world, right? This is so exciting. Sitting here spying on you guys is a really weird, thrilling feeling.
Yeah.
I apologize for all the coffee chat.
All our trash.
It's so great.
I want 45 minutes of that and three of me and then we're...
Well, you're in...
Guess what?
Yeah.
Yeah. I apologize for all the coffee chat. All our trash. It's so great. I want 45 minutes of that and three of me and then we're... Well, you're in... Guess what? Yeah.
Here it comes.
It doesn't get any better.
Yeah, our favorite is to ask you a question
and then tell you what our answer is for that question
and then whatever time remains you can tell.
Oh, I know.
I'm a long-time listener.
Here it comes. It doesn't get any better. It doesn't get any better. Yeah, our favorite is to ask you a question and then tell you what our answer is for that question and then whatever time remains you can tell. Oh, I know. I'm a long-time listener.
Are you?
Big fan.
Who's your favorite?
Yeah, of course.
You're my favorite because you brought me on.
Will didn't, even though Will and I just worked together.
We did.
Are you? Big fan. Who's your favorite? Yeah, of course. You're my favorite because you brought me on. Will didn't, even though Will and I just worked together. We did. We did.
That's right.
Did you guys have scenes together?
We did.
Really?
Yeah.
Pivotal scene.
We did. That's right. Did you guys have scenes together? We did. Really? Yeah. Pivotal scene. Pivotal scene.
We don't want to say too much.
Let's go ahead. Let's start with that.
Let's tell them about your film coming out, y'all.
We're in a film called Behemoth.
I'll say.
It's behemoth.
And directed by Tony Gilroy.
The great Tony Gilroy.
We don't want to say too much. Let's go ahead. Let's start with that. Let's tell them about your film coming out, y'all. We're in a film called Behemoth. I'll say. It's behemoth. And directed by Tony Gilroy. The great Tony Gilroy.
The coolest.
Is the coolest guy of all time.
Hey, Will, why don't you try to book him, huh?
Yeah, why don't we get him on?
I'd love to have it.
I am going to get Tony.
We have to.
Oh, my God.
The coolest. Is the coolest guy of all time. Hey, Will, why don't you try to book him, huh? Yeah, why don't we get him on? I'd love to have it. I am going to get Tony. We have to. Oh, my God.
Dude.
By the way, listener, please look Tony Gilroy up and you'll be amazed.
Just his credits alone, he's just incredible.
Michael Clayton, his first film somehow, which is bananas.
That's a great movie.
Yeah, that he directed.
He's an incredible writer, but that's a perfect movie.
It's Robert Ellswitt to be the DP on that, right out of the gate.
Dude. By the way, listener, please look Tony Gilroy up and you'll be amazed. Just his credits alone, he's just incredible. Michael Clayton, his first film somehow, which is bananas. That's a great movie. Yeah, that he directed. He's an incredible writer, but that's a perfect movie. It's Robert Ellswitt to be the DP on that, right out of the gate.
It's crazy.
It's like Citizen Kane.
He's like, how about this?
I'll try this job, and it's perfect.
But he's so cool and so chill.
And he makes it look so easy.
I was just entirely obsessed with him and his wife.
It's crazy. It's crazy. It's like Citizen Kane. He's like, how about this? I'll try this job, and it's perfect. But he's so cool and so chill. And he makes it look so easy. I was just entirely obsessed with him and his wife.
He's got a real cool,
like you and Amanda Jason.
He's like that.
They're like just cool and obsessed with each other.
Amanda's cool.
She cares of cool for both of us.
Yeah.
Yeah, the great Tony Gilroy.
He's got a real cool, like you and Amanda Jason. He's like that. They're like just cool and obsessed with each other. Amanda's cool. She cares of cool for both of us. Yeah. Yeah, the great Tony Gilroy.
God, we love him.
We love him.
I will say, can I tell you something funny?
Olivia happened to me last week.
I want to listen.
Let me listen.
I had, well, I guess so.
This is for us.
God, we love him. We love him. I will say, can I tell you something funny? Olivia happened to me last week. I want to listen. Let me listen. I had, well, I guess so. This is for us.
So I had dinner with Tony like two weeks ago.
Oh, yeah.
And here in L.A.
And then I...
You talk about reshooting your stuff?
That's weird.
I was here.
But anyway, keep going.
So I had dinner with Tony like two weeks ago. Oh, yeah. And here in L.A. And then I... You talk about reshooting your stuff? That's weird. I was here. But anyway, keep going.
We just got to you.
And I, we split the bill.
So we both put our cards down when we signed the thing, whatever.
We split.
Surprised you got half out of you.
Couple days later.
No, I did go through the bill.
We just got to you. And I, we split the bill. So we both put our cards down when we signed the thing, whatever. We split. Surprised you got half out of you. Couple days later. Couple days later. No, I did go through the bill.
I kept going, you had two drinks, right?
You had, did that even touch?
Who had the French?
If I'm looking at the dessert, like, I never even touched it.
And so then we spent, and then a couple days later, I go shopping to buy a few new items to get some clothes.
And the bill was pretty hefty.
And I give him the card.
The guy gets it back.
I kept going, you had two drinks, right? You had, did that even touch? Who had the French? If I'm looking at the dessert, like, I never even touched it. And so then we spent, and then a couple days later, I go shopping to buy a few new items to get some clothes. And the bill was pretty hefty. And I give him the card. The guy gets it back.
And he hands me the card back.
And I'm talking to my friend.
And I look down and it says Tony Gilroy on the credit card.
Yeah.
So I go over and then I text him.
I go, hey man.
So listen, you're about to get a big charge.
Thanks for the tops.
And he hands me the card back. And I'm talking to my friend. And I look down and it says Tony Gilroy on the credit card. Yeah. So I go over and then I text him. I go, hey man. So listen, you're about to get a big charge. Thanks for the tops.
And so he goes, oh, shit.
And he goes, I'm going back to your IQ.
He goes, all right, I'll come over and grab it from you.
I'm right around the corner.
And he goes, he goes, I don't, I'm trying to think if I bought anything in the last couple days.
And there's a pause in the text.
And he goes, the only thing I thought,
I think I bought,
And so he goes, oh, shit. And he goes, I'm going back to your IQ. He goes, all right, I'll come over and grab it from you. I'm right around the corner. And he goes, he goes, I don't, I'm trying to think if I bought anything in the last couple days. And there's a pause in the text. And he goes, the only thing I thought, I think I bought,
embarrassingly enough,
are mothballs.
What?
That's relatable.
So anyway,
he's got some guys got a lot of cashmere.
He's got to protect it.
He does, he does, a lot of cashmere.
embarrassingly enough, are mothballs. What? That's relatable. So anyway, he's got some guys got a lot of cashmere. He's got to protect it. He does, he does, a lot of cashmere.
He's stylish.
But this movie is starring Pedro Pescal,
and I have no idea when it comes out,
but it's going to be so good
because there are at least seven composers
on that film.
It's a film about
He's stylish. He's stylish. But this movie is starring Pedro Pescal, and I have no idea when it comes out, but it's going to be so good because there are at least seven composers on that film. It's a film about
music and Pedro plays a cellist and you also play a musician.
Did you get to play music in the movie?
No, no.
I'm kind of...
I read it.
I think I read it.
No, I read it.
What instrument did they say your character played well?
music and Pedro plays a cellist and you also play a musician. Did you get to play music in the movie? No, no. I'm kind of... I read it. I think I read it. No, I read it. What instrument did they say your character played well?
They just said it's just a bunch.
He's just kind of like an all-around kind of...
Whatever's available?
Yeah, and he's a dude kind of...
He often, like, I don't know if you're catching my 10,000-yard stare.
The guy's got a lot going on inside, you know.
I love when you wet the reed.
Hopefully it's something for the wind instrument.
They just said it's just a bunch. He's just kind of like an all-around kind of... Whatever's available? Yeah, and he's a dude kind of... He often, like, I don't know if you're catching my 10,000-yard stare. The guy's got a lot going on inside, you know. I love when you wet the reed. Hopefully it's something for the wind instrument.
And let the spit out.
Yeah.
So truly, it's about, it's about conductors, composers.
Sort of, right?
Yeah, and like film composition, like music for film.
And it's kind of a love letter to that world.
And they show that process, which is so cool.
That's cool.
And let the spit out. Yeah. So truly, it's about, it's about conductors, composers. Sort of, right? Yeah, and like film composition, like music for film. And it's kind of a love letter to that world. And they show that process, which is so cool. That's cool.
Wow.
Yeah, that is something that.
that your average movie goer does not get a chance to learn about that much.
Exactly.
It's fascinating.
It's really, really fascinating, kind of getting in and out of them.
The people who inhabit that world and what they are, and, you know,
and some of them are just the most brilliant.
Wow. Yeah, that is something that. that your average movie goer does not get a chance to learn about that much. Exactly. It's fascinating. It's really, really fascinating, kind of getting in and out of them. The people who inhabit that world and what they are, and, you know, and some of them are just the most brilliant.
And Will plays Pedro's brother.
Yeah.
Put that together in your head.
Wow.
Make that make sense.
And it does because you're that good.
It was the tan.
It's the tan that you currently have.
And Will plays Pedro's brother. Yeah. Put that together in your head. Wow. Make that make sense. And it does because you're that good. It was the tan. It's the tan that you currently have.
That's why he's still wearing all the makeup.
Thank you.
No.
You guys.
All right, well, let's...
Talk about me like I'm not here.
No.
All right.
That's why he's still wearing all the makeup. Thank you. No. You guys. All right, well, let's... Talk about me like I'm not here. No. All right.
So, we've, we've got, we started at the end.
Let's go back to the beginning.
Hey, Livy.
1942.
I don't think I've ever called you, Livy.
Now, this has gotten some press before, and I apologize to ask you about it.
But maybe some of our listeners have discussed it.
Buckle up.
So, we've, we've got, we started at the end. Let's go back to the beginning. Hey, Livy. 1942. I don't think I've ever called you, Livy. Now, this has gotten some press before, and I apologize to ask you about it. But maybe some of our listeners have discussed it. Buckle up.
But it's, but it's, but it's, it's, it's cute.
You don't like it.
You had to change your name, didn't you, doll?
I, you know, I didn't have to.
I chose to.
Well, you kind of had to.
Let's walk the audience through the original name.
Oh, yeah, I don't know this.
But it's, but it's, but it's, it's, it's, it's cute. You don't like it. You had to change your name, didn't you, doll? I, you know, I didn't have to. I chose to. Well, you kind of had to. Let's walk the audience through the original name. Oh, yeah, I don't know this.
What's the original name?
Yeah, it's fun.
It's real fun.
It's fun.
But it's, but it's got some real lineage to it, too.
So go ahead here, guest.
You talk.
Okay, thank you so much.
What's the original name? Yeah, it's fun. It's real fun. It's fun. But it's, but it's got some real lineage to it, too. So go ahead here, guest. You talk. Okay, thank you so much.
I was born with a different name.
Oh.
My family name is actually.
Coburn, but it's pronounced coburn, but it's spelled.
And I'm going to, I weirdly have a visual for this.
Listener, you won't get it, but it's for these guys.
But my last name is...
Oh, wow.
I was born with a different name. Oh. My family name is actually. Coburn, but it's pronounced coburn, but it's spelled. And I'm going to, I weirdly have a visual for this. Listener, you won't get it, but it's for these guys. But my last name is... Oh, wow.
Cockburn.
You were just talking about Cockburn, like two days ago.
Right?
By the way, I'm still talking about it.
When are you not talking about it?
I don't forget, but that particularly it was behind a dumpster.
Anyway, whatever.
Cockburn. Cockburn. You were just talking about Cockburn, like two days ago. Right? By the way, I'm still talking about it. When are you not talking about it? I don't forget, but that particularly it was behind a dumpster. Anyway, whatever.
Yeah, you had a real case of the cockburn.
I mean, if anybody has any ointment or anything,
let me know.
Wait, it's really pronounced Coburn?
It's, okay, but this is the thing.
That's not unusual.
In Scotland, it is pronounced Coburn.
I've never expected anyone in my life to ever be able to get that, to predict that.
Yeah, you had a real case of the cockburn. I mean, if anybody has any ointment or anything, let me know. Wait, it's really pronounced Coburn? It's, okay, but this is the thing. That's not unusual. In Scotland, it is pronounced Coburn. I've never expected anyone in my life to ever be able to get that, to predict that.
So from me...
C-O-C-K, by his way, so people can say...
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, C-O-C-K-B-U-R-N.
Cochburn.
Very literally how you would imagine it being spelled.
And it's a name...
to grow up with to build character.
You know, it's a boy named Sue.
So from me... C-O-C-K, by his way, so people can say... Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, C-O-C-K-B-U-R-N. Cochburn. Very literally how you would imagine it being spelled. And it's a name... to grow up with to build character. You know, it's a boy named Sue.
And it, yeah, my family are all amazing writers and journalists and just badass people.
And that book you just held up, is that somebody from your family?
That, yeah, this is my sweet assistant has built this little tower for the microphone and she happened to use all of these books that are written by my family just to intimidate me.
That's amazing.
To remind me I haven't done shit in my life.
And they're very impressive.
But they're all amazing, yeah.
Well, then, but so A, how early did you change the name?
And it, yeah, my family are all amazing writers and journalists and just badass people. And that book you just held up, is that somebody from your family? That, yeah, this is my sweet assistant has built this little tower for the microphone and she happened to use all of these books that are written by my family just to intimidate me. That's amazing. To remind me I haven't done shit in my life. And they're very impressive. But they're all amazing, yeah. Well, then, but so A, how early did you change the name?
Right.
You landed on Wild because of your affinity for?
Oscar.
Oh, wow.
Yes, and so I changed it when I was 18.
I write when you legally can, if you can believe it.
But hang on, but you went through the toughest teasing years with that name.
Oh, yeah.
Right. You landed on Wild because of your affinity for? Oscar. Oh, wow. Yes, and so I changed it when I was 18. I write when you legally can, if you can believe it. But hang on, but you went through the toughest teasing years with that name. Oh, yeah.
How'd that go?
I truly think it's good for you.
I think that everyone should be given one really devastating part of their name.
I was just talking to Dax about this because he also,
this was also where he wanted to start.
He was like, yeah.
We are a child of that podcast.
That's true.
How'd that go? I truly think it's good for you. I think that everyone should be given one really devastating part of their name. I was just talking to Dax about this because he also, this was also where he wanted to start. He was like, yeah. We are a child of that podcast. That's true.
I've never spoken to Dax about his name.
What do we know about, what do we know about Dax's first name?
It's actually Cockburn?
Yeah.
But like, what is, what is, is Dax?
Dax is actually his name.
No, I think it's Dax.
No, he's born Daxil, right?
I've never spoken to Dax about his name. What do we know about, what do we know about Dax's first name? It's actually Cockburn? Yeah. But like, what is, what is, is Dax? Dax is actually his name. No, I think it's Dax. No, he's born Daxil, right?
I forget why his mom.
Daxil.
What was the deal with that?
What's that weird?
I've never asked him about that.
Daxil.
I have and I forget.
I forget why his mom. Daxil. What was the deal with that? Daxil. What's that weird? I've never asked him about that. Daxil. I have and I forget.
Daxil.
So, wait a minute.
Olivia, so, so, did you, so, when you, so 18, why 18?
Because, so you wanted to change it forever?
Well, no, I'm, you know, I moved out here.
I came right from boarding school.
I came right to,
and I was a casting assistant and I was doing, I was going to auditions and I was like,
Daxil. So, wait a minute. Olivia, so, so, did you, so, when you, so 18, why 18? Because, so you wanted to change it forever? Well, no, I'm, you know, I moved out here. I came right from boarding school. I came right to, and I was a casting assistant and I was doing, I was going to auditions and I was like,
I want to forge my own path and I wanted to change my name.
And I had like great affinity for other people who had done that.
I thought it was really cool when other people had done that.
And I was like, what would I do?
And the first play I did that I really loved was the importance of being earnest.
And then I read everything that Oscar Wilde wrote and I just became obsessed with.
with him and he's Irish, my family's Irish.
So that's how it happened.
I want to forge my own path and I wanted to change my name. And I had like great affinity for other people who had done that. I thought it was really cool when other people had done that. And I was like, what would I do? And the first play I did that I really loved was the importance of being earnest. And then I read everything that Oscar Wilde wrote and I just became obsessed with. with him and he's Irish, my family's Irish. So that's how it happened.
Yeah, it's such a great name.
Yeah, I didn't think it would be interpreted so like pornographically.
Like the first 10 years of my career, every headline, every magazine was just like,
get wild, like, born to be wild, wet and wild.
And I was like, oh, fuck, I didn't really think this through.
Could use a little cockburn right now.
She kept it as a middle name.
I did, yeah.
Yeah, it's such a great name. Yeah, I didn't think it would be interpreted so like pornographically. Like the first 10 years of my career, every headline, every magazine was just like, get wild, like, born to be wild, wet and wild. And I was like, oh, fuck, I didn't really think this through. Could use a little cockburn right now. She kept it as a middle name. I did, yeah.
No.
Wait, but what about being an assistant casting director?
Was that, now, I would imagine that would have given you some comfort as you started auditioning
that you'd kind of been on the other side of it and you kind of, was it less intimidating?
You know, I did it because Keener had done it.
Oh, really?
I was obsessed with Catherine Keener and she had done it.
Catherine Keener.
No. Wait, but what about being an assistant casting director? Was that, now, I would imagine that would have given you some comfort as you started auditioning that you'd kind of been on the other side of it and you kind of, was it less intimidating? You know, I did it because Keener had done it. Oh, really? I was obsessed with Catherine Keener and she had done it. Catherine Keener.
And it's not something most casting directors will let you do.
Like, they don't usually hire wannabe actors because it's like dangerous.
You have little spies in the office.
But I worked for Mally Finn.
Do you guys remember Mally?
Did you have a audition?
Yeah.
She was a legend.
And it's not something most casting directors will let you do. Like, they don't usually hire wannabe actors because it's like dangerous. You have little spies in the office. But I worked for Mally Finn. Do you guys remember Mally? Did you have a audition? Yeah. She was a legend.
And so I worked for her first when I was 16 and then when I was 18.
So when I was 16, I did it for a summer.
And then she let me come back at 18 and have a real job.
And I worked there for almost a year.
And it was wild.
I really saw how the sausage was made.
So were you outside like in the sort of reception area and watching everyone practice their faces and mop their brow?
Oh, my God.
And so I worked for her first when I was 16 and then when I was 18. So when I was 16, I did it for a summer. And then she let me come back at 18 and have a real job. And I worked there for almost a year. And it was wild. I really saw how the sausage was made. So were you outside like in the sort of reception area and watching everyone practice their faces and mop their brow? Oh, my God.
And it was so many people I later worked with.
And I was like, I've seen you in another light when you're mad at me because it's taking too long and parking is annoying and you're late and you want coffee.
Uh-huh.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
Did it help you at all, like, understand the audition process?
Like, did you feel like it gave you leg up?
And it was so many people I later worked with. And I was like, I've seen you in another light when you're mad at me because it's taking too long and parking is annoying and you're late and you want coffee. Uh-huh. We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. Did it help you at all, like, understand the audition process? Like, did you feel like it gave you leg up?
Yeah.
Also, she had crazy high standards.
So she would not accept anybody unprepared or not off book.
Like, she would stop people.
and say, why don't you come back
when you've done the work?
And I loved that it gave me this sense of like,
you better be really prepared.
Yeah. Also, she had crazy high standards. So she would not accept anybody unprepared or not off book. Like, she would stop people. and say, why don't you come back when you've done the work? And I loved that it gave me this sense of like, you better be really prepared.
Like I never have gone to an audition
without being prepared.
But she had crazy stories.
And the thing that I love is that
while I was working there,
there was like this great legend.
Hang on, let me drink my coffee because...
Go ahead.
Like I never have gone to an audition without being prepared. But she had crazy stories. And the thing that I love is that while I was working there, there was like this great legend. Hang on, let me drink my coffee because... Go ahead.
We'll pause.
I'll show it right out.
Okay.
Smooth as silk.
Oh, yeah.
So while I was working there,
there was like the legend
of the Sam Rockwell audition.
We'll pause. I'll show it right out. Okay. Smooth as silk. Oh, yeah. So while I was working there, there was like the legend of the Sam Rockwell audition.
And it was like,
she would tell us, like, the best audition I've ever seen was Sam Rockwell auditioning for the Green Mile.
Jason's directing him right now.
Let me tell you this, and please repeat this to him at work today.
So she said, he came in, and it was the last day of the director's sessions, the last possible day you could audition, and he came in and he had been given the wrong scenes.
And this man, Sam Rockwell, he didn't even pause. He said, well, give me the correct scenes and I'll go learn them really quick.
And they said, that's impossible, Sam.
It's 10 pages of dialogue.
And it was like, she would tell us, like, the best audition I've ever seen was Sam Rockwell auditioning for the Green Mile. Jason's directing him right now. Let me tell you this, and please repeat this to him at work today. So she said, he came in, and it was the last day of the director's sessions, the last possible day you could audition, and he came in and he had been given the wrong scenes. And this man, Sam Rockwell, he didn't even pause. He said, well, give me the correct scenes and I'll go learn them really quick. And they said, that's impossible, Sam. It's 10 pages of dialogue.
You can't possibly.
No one could do it.
And he was like, just give me a chance.
I don't want to miss this opportunity.
So they gave him the right scenes.
He goes into the hallway.
They only have five minutes to give him to learn the lines.
He comes back in and he nails it.
You can't possibly. No one could do it. And he was like, just give me a chance. I don't want to miss this opportunity. So they gave him the right scenes. He goes into the hallway. They only have five minutes to give him to learn the lines. He comes back in and he nails it.
And they were floored.
And he got the role.
And she said, that, that's an actor who can work that quickly.
So years later, I'm working with Sam and I'm sitting next to him in the makeup chair.
And I was like, Sam, it's so nice to meet you.
What an honor.
I have to tell you.
I always heard this story when I was an assistant
And they were floored. And he got the role. And she said, that, that's an actor who can work that quickly. So years later, I'm working with Sam and I'm sitting next to him in the makeup chair. And I was like, Sam, it's so nice to meet you. What an honor. I have to tell you. I always heard this story when I was an assistant
and it just really inspired me
and he goes, oh, yeah,
that was like a thing I used to do.
That worked every time.
Oh, really?
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, that's great.
I have been...
and it just really inspired me and he goes, oh, yeah, that was like a thing I used to do. That worked every time. Oh, really? And I was like, are you fucking kidding me? Oh, that's great. I have been...
Brilliant.
Like, I thought that this...
I revered his ability to, like, flash memorize.
He knew he had the correct size.
It was a whole performance.
Oh, my God.
So, it is.
And it's so genius because it lowers their expectations.
Brilliant. Like, I thought that this... I revered his ability to, like, flash memorize. He knew he had the correct size. It was a whole performance. Oh, my God. So, it is. And it's so genius because it lowers their expectations.
Then if you even like say half the things right, they're like, God damn, this man learned this in five minutes.
He's a crafty bugger.
He's a real operator of that rockbacker.
I better keep my knees bent.
This is that guy.
He's like, and the way it's so standing, he's like, oh, yeah.
That's just like a thing I used to do.
Oh, yeah.
Then if you even like say half the things right, they're like, God damn, this man learned this in five minutes. He's a crafty bugger. He's a real operator of that rockbacker. I better keep my knees bent. This is that guy. He's like, and the way it's so standing, he's like, oh, yeah. That's just like a thing I used to do. Oh, yeah.
And I was like, wow.
He deserves an Oscar.
I don't know if I told this before, but we can cut this out of it's boring.
Already too boring?
No, no, we're good.
Sean, cut, pre-cut.
Pre-cut.
So I went to go audition for the bucket list
And I was like, wow. He deserves an Oscar. I don't know if I told this before, but we can cut this out of it's boring. Already too boring? No, no, we're good. Sean, cut, pre-cut. Pre-cut. So I went to go audition for the bucket list
with the brilliant Rod Reiner, rest of the soul.
He was amazing.
And I walked in, and I had the wrong sides, right?
I worked on it for a long time.
And I walked in and I had all, like,
it wasn't even slightly wrong.
It was completely rewrote all these scenes.
And I started auditioning with the scene,
with the brilliant Rod Reiner, rest of the soul. He was amazing. And I walked in, and I had the wrong sides, right? I worked on it for a long time. And I walked in and I had all, like, it wasn't even slightly wrong. It was completely rewrote all these scenes. And I started auditioning with the scene,
and he's like, what are you doing?
I'm like, what do you mean?
And he's like, who gave you these sides?
I'm my agent?
He's like, no, there's a,
a whole new script.
And he's like, I'm like, I didn't know that.
I go, great.
and he's like, what are you doing? I'm like, what do you mean? And he's like, who gave you these sides? I'm my agent? He's like, no, there's a, a whole new script. And he's like, I'm like, I didn't know that. I go, great.
Then let me come back a week later and I'll go work on him.
So I work on them and I had this bit already and I walk in and it's just me and Rob and
like a couple producers and a cast writer.
And I was like, you ready?
He's like, yeah.
And then I started going, why did you order the so bad, like the horse acting you've
ever seen on purpose?
I go, why did you order the code read?
Then let me come back a week later and I'll go work on him. So I work on them and I had this bit already and I walk in and it's just me and Rob and like a couple producers and a cast writer. And I was like, you ready? He's like, yeah. And then I started going, why did you order the so bad, like the horse acting you've ever seen on purpose? I go, why did you order the code read?
I didn't tell you to order the code red.
You want the truth.
You can't handle the truth.
No, no.
And I stopped, and he's laughing, and I go, did I get the wrong side?
That's really great.
I started doing the scene from a few good men.
That's so good.
I didn't tell you to order the code red. You want the truth. You can't handle the truth. No, no. And I stopped, and he's laughing, and I go, did I get the wrong side? That's really great. I started doing the scene from a few good men. That's so good.
Did he give me the part?
Yeah, I got it, yeah.
Nice.
Very nice.
So nice.
So now, Olivia, now that you're on the other side of the table in these auditions as you're directing these things, are you incredibly more compassionate?
Yes.
And I take, like, 12 hours per session because I'm like, you go.
Did he give me the part? Yeah, I got it, yeah. Nice. Very nice. So nice. So now, Olivia, now that you're on the other side of the table in these auditions as you're directing these things, are you incredibly more compassionate? Yes. And I take, like, 12 hours per session because I'm like, you go.
I want to hear it all, even if I know from the first moment that it's not going to be them,
I'm like, this is your time.
And it's a disaster for everyone else because I will milk it.
It's so hard.
Auditioning is a fucking nightmare.
And these people, they come and it's so vulnerable.
And, yeah, being on that side definitely made me a little kinder.
But there's so much more also self-tapping now, right?
I want to hear it all, even if I know from the first moment that it's not going to be them, I'm like, this is your time. And it's a disaster for everyone else because I will milk it. It's so hard. Auditioning is a fucking nightmare. And these people, they come and it's so vulnerable. And, yeah, being on that side definitely made me a little kinder. But there's so much more also self-tapping now, right?
It's all self-tape, isn't it?
Oh, yeah.
That part seems fantastic, right?
where you can just record your audio show.
Then the pressure's off.
I like the room.
Yeah.
It's all self-tape, isn't it? Oh, yeah. That part seems fantastic, right? where you can just record your audio show. Then the pressure's off. I like the room. I like the room. Yeah.
What if you don't do well?
What if you forget your lines?
With the self-tapes, you don't send it until you're happy with it.
But you overthink it.
I mean, can you imagine how much?
The overthinking and also what I find is when people send me tapes,
they've overthought the framing, the lighting.
People have full setups now, and I'm like, you don't need that.
What if you don't do well? What if you forget your lines? With the self-tapes, you don't send it until you're happy with it. But you overthink it. I mean, can you imagine how much? The overthinking and also what I find is when people send me tapes, they've overthought the framing, the lighting. People have full setups now, and I'm like, you don't need that.
I'd rather have someone's like shitty iPhone selfie video in their car
on the way to their real job,
than like a red light.
Yeah.
Rather than like a full setup that I'm like,
you didn't have to do that for me.
I don't need all this.
But Olivia, what made you,
I'd rather have someone's like shitty iPhone selfie video in their car on the way to their real job, than like a red light. Yeah. Rather than like a full setup that I'm like, you didn't have to do that for me. I don't need all this. But Olivia, what made you,
how did you know that you wanted to just move to Los Angeles
and work in a casting director's office?
Well, truly keener.
You moved from where?
I read the keener done it.
I was at boarding school in Massachusetts.
Okay.
Who went to boarding school here?
how did you know that you wanted to just move to Los Angeles and work in a casting director's office? Well, truly keener. You moved from where? I read the keener done it. I was at boarding school in Massachusetts. Okay. Who went to boarding school here?
You said somebody did.
Oh, you did?
Where did you go?
In Canada.
We don't talk about it.
We had a bad break.
Board of School and I had a bad break up.
Okay.
You said somebody did. Oh, you did? Where did you go? In Canada. We don't talk about it. We had a bad break. Board of School and I had a bad break up. Okay.
Yeah.
Well, mine was, it's tough, but I went to a fancy one.
I can't complain.
It was very bougie.
But I graduated and left the suburbs of Massachusetts.
After growing up in New York and then D.C.,
and I had never spent much time in the West Coast.
I thought L.A. sounded like this, like, incredible mecca of excitement.
是的。嗯，我的嘛，挺不容易的，但我去了一所很好的学校。我没什么好抱怨的。那里非常小布尔乔亚。但我毕业后离开了马萨诸塞州的郊区。在纽约和华盛顿长大之后，我以前从未在西海岸待过太久。我觉得洛杉矶听起来就像是一个令人难以置信的充满刺激的圣地。
And I came out here and took like two city buses to work every day in the casting office.
And then started auditioning and, you know, kind of like scraped my way up slowly.
But it was really the dream from the beginning.
So for me, it was very exciting.
How about that?
That's cool.
And where did you stay when you came out?
Did you move into the Oakwoods?
我来到这里，每天坐两趟城市公交车去选角办公室上班。然后开始试镜，你知道的，有点像是一点点慢慢混出来的。但这从一开始就是我的梦想。所以对我说，这非常令人兴奋。怎么样？这很酷。你刚来的时候住在哪里？你搬进奥克斯伍德公寓了吗？
No, that would have been fun.
That sounded so fun for those people.
I did.
I did a few pilot seasons.
So for Tracy, that's a place where the actors would go stay when they came.
It was like a corporate housing, and there would be that thing.
I remember pilot season, you'd have like six auditions a day,
and you're not getting anything.
不，那应该会很有趣。对那些人来说听起来太有趣了。我确实参加过几次试播集季。所以对特雷西来说，那是演员们刚来时住的地方。那就像是公司提供的宿舍，会有那种东西。我记得试播集季，你一天可能会有六场试镜，但什么也捞不到。
And the back gate is on Barham over there,
on the way down the hill towards Warner Brothers.
And on the back gate, when you leave, there's a sign on the gate,
and you had to wait for it to slowly open.
And it said, smile at showtime.
Oh, cool.
So dark.
And there'd be day, and it's like February, and it's raining all day,
后门在那边的巴勒姆路上，顺着山坡往下走就是华纳兄弟。在后门，当你离开时，门上有一个标志，你得等它慢慢打开。上面写着，微哦，笑迎演出时刻。哦，太酷了。真黑暗。有时候是白天，就像二月份，整天都在下雨，
and you're, like, going back for a crappy pilot,
and you're just feeling like, I'm like,
Oh, so hard.
I'm worthless.
I'm 31, nothing is happening.
Smile, it's show time.
Fuck me, man.
Well, I had given myself a limit
然后你，你知道，又要回去接一个烂透了的试播集，你心里就会觉得，我心想，哦，太难了。我真一无是处。我31岁了，什么也没发生。微笑，演出时刻。真他妈的，老兄。好吧，我给自己设了一个期限，
because I had taken a, I deferred from college
and I was like, I'm giving myself a year
or like nine months.
And if I don't book anything in that time,
I'll go.
I think that's good.
I think giving yourself a little bit of a deadline.
What was the thing that you would have gone back
因为我曾向学校申请过延期入学，当时我想，我给自己一年的时间，或者大概九个月。如果在那段时间里我没有接到任何工作，我就走。我觉得这挺好的。我觉得给自己设一个小小的截止日期挺好。你会回去学什么呢？
and studied in college?
I mean, acting.
I mean, it would have, I think
I think I would have studied, I really probably would have become a writer like everyone else in my
family or I would have tried.
But now if I went back, which I like to fantasize about, I think it would be like completely,
I think I want to study neuroscience.
I'd like to go and do, wouldn't that be cool?
如果在大学里重新学习？我是说，表演。我是说，我觉得，我想我可能会去学，我大概真的会像我家里的其他人一样成为一个作家，或者我会去尝试一下。但如果我现在回去，这是我喜欢幻想的事情，我觉得那会是完全不同的，我想我想学神经科学。我想去读，那不是很酷吗？
There'd be a bunch of math I'd have to catch up on though, which is not.
I've got a couple of friends that are doctors and I just, they walk on water to me.
I just like, that's really, like, you certainly aren't born with any sort of natural talent to
cut people's brains open and fix it.
Right?
Like you could be born with talent to throw a football 100 yards or whatever, but you don't
come out with it.
So it's all learned.
不过我得补习一大堆数学，这可不太妙。我有几个医生朋友，在眼里他们就像神一样。我只是觉得，那真的很厉害，你绝对不是天生就有切开别人的大脑并把它修好的天赋。对吧？就像你可能天生就有扔美式橄榄球100码的天赋之类的，但你生来可没有这种本事。所以这全都是后天学习得来的。
You have to learn so much and you don't learn it until you read it or it's explained to you.
Jason respects discipline.
He respects discipline.
Yes.
And self-education.
I just,
I think it's incredible.
I wonder if they are born though with something.
你必须学习大量的知识，而且在读到它或有人向你解释之前，你是学不到的。杰森尊重纪律。他尊重纪律。是的，还有自我教育。我只是，我觉得这太不可思议了。我想知道他们是不是真的生来就带点什么。
Maybe you are born with.
Well, you just have to, an affinity to want.
Yeah, or learn.
That's why I'd get into neuroscience because I'd want to get in there and see if they are born with it.
Like, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Get in.
You cut them open and look for natural talent.
也许你生来就有。好吧，你只是必须有，一种想要去了解的渴望。是的，或者去学习。这就是为什么我要去研究神经科学，因为我想钻研进去看看他们是不是天生就有的。就像，你知道我的意思吗？对。进去看看。你把他们切开然后寻找天生天赋。
Yeah, you fucking dummy.
That's why I'm doing it.
Yeah.
You think Dr. Gary walks on water, by the way?
I do.
He's an emergency room physician.
No, you disrespect his golf game because he's so straight and he's always in the fair way.
But what about, I have a friend that's like, he's like, I don't trust doctors.
对，你这个他妈的笨蛋。这就是我要这么做的原因。是的，顺便问一下，你觉得加里医生像神一样吗？我是这么觉得的。他是急诊室医生。不，你只是不尊重他的高尔夫球技，因为他的球总是直直的，而且总是在球道上。但是，我有个朋友说，他觉得，他总是说，我不信任医生。
I don't believe in them.
I think, you know, statins.
Like, just, he goes on and on about, like, what...
You're talking about RFK Jr.?
Yeah.
Your top dog?
Yeah, he's...
I'm having dinner with him tonight.
我不相信他们。我觉得，你知道，他汀类药物。就，他喋喋不休地说着，比如，什么……你是在说小罗伯特·F·肯尼迪吗？对。你的头号偶像？对，他……我今晚要和他共进晚餐。
No.
Top dog.
No, but, like, what do you think about these people
who don't ever...
Who constantly put doctors down?
I'm with you.
I'm like, I've taken the two choices
about someone who, you know,
不是吧。头号偶像。不，但是，你对这些从不……总是贬低医生的人怎么看？我跟你一样。我就觉得，我做出了两种选择，一种是关于那些，你知道的，
stuff you read online or, like, self-help, whatever,
and somebody who's studying...
it day in and day out, I'm going to go with the guy who studied it.
Yeah, just assuming that those doctors must be wrong.
Like, wait, what?
Also, there's a bigger conspiracy at play here that they're looking to take the,
what does it, take the world over?
They've all organized and figured out how to trick us all.
你在网上读到的东西，或者自我疗愈什么的，而另一个人则是日复一日地在学习……我会选择那个深入研究过的人。是的，只是想当然地认为那些医生一定是错的。就像，等等，什么？此外，这里面还有一个更大的阴谋，他们试图夺取，怎么说来着，统治全世界？他们全都串通好了，想出了如何戏弄我们所有人的办法。
Sean, do you think Sean trust doctors too much.
I mean, I would say that maybe.
Yeah, he's got a punch card at Cedars.
No, he's, they call him paddles when he comes in.
He's got a-fid and he's always getting it fired up.
I mean, I had to play a doctor to be anywhere near it.
House.
Let's talk about house.
肖恩，你觉得肖恩是不是太信任医生了。我的意思是，可能会吧。是的，他在雪松医院有一张积分卡。不，他，当他来的时候他们叫他“电击器”。他有房颤，总是得去电击复律。我是说，我必须扮演一个医生才能离那儿近一点。豪斯医生。我们来聊聊豪斯医生吧。
That wasn't me trying to like segue into my career at all.
No, no.
We appreciate the help.
And for our Canadian listeners, it's the show known as House.
Yes, created by Canadians.
Wasn't that next door to us over there on the Fox Lott for arrest development?
I thought you meant Canada.
Oh, man.
我刚才可不是在试图顺便提及我的演艺生涯。不，不。我们很感激这种帮助。对于我们的加拿大听众来说，这就是那部名为《豪斯医生》的剧。是的，由加拿大人创作。那不就在福克斯片场《发展受阻》剧组隔壁吗？我还以为你指的是加拿大呢。哦，天哪。
I wish I was on your show.
I wish we were all back on the 20th lot.
Wasn't that great?
Just going to Apple Pan every day for lunch.
Apple Pans for my life.
Is that still there?
Oh, yeah.
Apple Pan.
我真希望我能上你的节目。我真希望我们都能回到20世纪福克斯片场。那不是很棒吗？每天午饭都去Apple Pan餐厅。Apple Pan就是我的命。那地方还在吗？哦，对。Apple Pan。
I think it is there.
I think Irving Azov by Apple Pan.
Didn't Irving Azov by Apple Pan? Or is that?
Or am I thinking of Nate Niles?
You're correct.
Sean, you go there after therapy.
So like once all the feelings come up, you go to stuff them back down?
Yes.
我想它还在。我觉得欧文·阿佐夫买下了Apple Pan。难道不是欧文·阿佐夫买下了Apple Pan吗？还是说？或者我想的是内特·尼尔斯？你说得对。肖恩，你做完心理治疗后就会去那儿。所以当所有的情绪涌上心头时，你就去把它们压下去？是的。
With the tuna melt and the milkshake.
Yes.
So good.
Fries.
All right.
So we're back.
We go back in the time machine.
用金枪鱼融化三明治和奶昔。是的。太棒了。薯条。好吧。好吧。所以我们回来了。我们坐时光机回去。
What is Olivia Co-Bose?
When she's a wee lass that's inspiring her to become an actor.
Okay, this is the thing.
I think about this a lot now.
My family, we watched a lot of comedy together.
And it is my greatest memory from childhood is the sound of my parents laughing and all of us laughing.
And my mom has a really funny thing.
She's still like cries when she laughs.
奥利维亚·科博斯是什么情况？当她还是个激励自己成为演员的小女孩时。好吧，就是这个。我现在经常想这个。我的家人，我们一起看很多喜剧。我童年最美好的回忆就是父母的笑声和我们所有人的笑声。我妈妈有一种特别搞笑的特质。她现在笑起来还是会哭。
And it's just adorable.
She always always to be like wiping away tears and my dad laughing so hard.
All of us.
And when I think about it,
It was a lot of comedy that I wouldn't have been absorbing the real meaning of.
I mean, a lot of...
Like taxi, all the family.
Yeah, and like, we watched, like, a lot of comedy that was probably little too adult.
而且超级可爱。她总是擦眼泪，我爸爸笑得那么厉害。我们所有人都是。当我回想起来，那里面有很多喜剧，我当时可能并不能领会其真正的含义。我是说，很多……比如《出租车司机》、《全家福》。是的，还有，我们看了很多可能有点太成人的喜剧。
And then a lot of, you know, we watched, like, Wayne's World a thousand times.
Like, for some reason, Wayne's World was, like, a huge movie in our family.
But a lot of SNL.
And it was a real joy to just sit and watch, you know, all the Monty Python together.
a lot.
Like we just, it was the best.
And I think for me, watching comedy,
even watching, like, for me, I love Lucy.
然后还有很多，你知道的，我们看了上千遍《韦恩的世界》。不知为什么，《韦恩的世界》对我们家来说是一部超级大电影。还有很多《周六夜现场》。坐在一起看，你知道的，一起看所有的《巨蟒剧团》，真的是一种真正的乐趣。看了很多。就像我们觉得，这是最棒的。而且我觉得对我来说，看喜剧，甚至看，比如对我来说，我爱露西。
I watch a lot of old comedy television.
Yeah, we do too.
I do too.
I watch Cheers a lot.
Cheers, the best.
I love cheers.
God, I love cheers.
And so I think about, like,
我看了很多老喜剧电视节目。是的，我们也看。我也看。我经常看《欢乐酒店》。《欢乐酒店》，最棒了。我爱《欢乐酒店》。天哪，我爱《欢乐酒店》。所以我就会想，
oh, of course that's where I find myself
now wanting to make comedies
because it's just,
I think it is probably the happiest memories from childhood.
I think I'm trying to recreate that feeling.
But did you go like,
Oh, I'm going to go and do this and I want to be in comedy?
Like, was that like a thing?
哦，难怪我现在发现自己想去拍喜剧，因为这绝对是我童年最快乐的回忆。我想我是在试图重现那种感觉。但你当时有没有想过，“哦，我要去搞这个，我想演喜剧”？就像，那是那种感觉吗？
Yes, yes.
Yeah, I think probably because I probably at the earliest stage
saw how happy it was making my parents.
Like I think, and then I would, I was the ham of the family.
And so I would make them laugh.
And then I would, I was the Hamun of the family.
And I would go and like just entertain everyone.
And they always had parties.
是的，是的。对，我想可能是因为我在最早的时候就看到这给我父母带来了多少快乐。就像我想的，然后我，我是家里的活宝。所以我总是逗他们笑。然后我，我是家里的活宝。我会去像这样逗每个人开心。他们以前总是办派对。
My parents were very social and very good hosts.
And so they had these amazing parties all the time.
and it was my joy in life to go and, like, perform as the little kid.
So, but I really think it was from watching all these great movies together.
And I think about it because I'm like, am I showing my kids enough, like, great films?
I hope so.
Jason, you're good about it with Frannie.
You've been so good about that.
我父母非常喜欢社交，也是非常棒的主办人。所以他们总是办这些精彩的派对。而我人生中的乐趣就是去像个小孩子一样表演。所以，但我真的觉得这是因为我们一起看了所有这些伟大的电影。我想起这个是因为我在想：我给我的孩子们看足够多伟大的电影了吗？希望如此。杰森，你对弗兰尼（Frannie）这方面做得很不错。你一直做得很好。
I put them in front of the TV before they could even speak because that was my upbringing.
I mean, that did, like, you know.
Because you were playing golf.
Well, there was that.
You're busy.
But, you know, they got to learn somehow, you know,
colors and numbers and things.
You've talked to the last couple of years.
我在他们还不会说话的时候就把他们放到电视机前了，因为我就是那样长大的。我是说，那确实，你知道的。因为你在打高尔夫球。嗯，有那回事。你很忙。但是，你知道的，他们总得学点什么，你知道的，颜色、数字之类的事。你过去几年一直在谈论这个。
Like you and Frannie talk about film and you sort of put a lot of good stuff in front
of her.
Like that's been important to you.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, really important to me.
Because that's what I had with my dad.
It was great subject matter and shared references.
And yeah, I just, I love it.
就像你和弗兰尼谈论电影，你基本上把很多好东西摆在她面前。这就像对你很重要。对，对，对，对我很重要。因为那是我和我爸爸一起做的事。那是很棒的主题和共同的参考点。而且，是的，我就是，我太喜欢了。
Yeah, you don't want to expose your four-year-old to the wire.
No.
You know, it's just like common sense.
I'm not afraid of screens.
It's the best.
And when they get it, it's so great.
but sometimes they'll be like,
they'll come back from their dad's house
对，你不会想让你四岁的孩子看《火线》（The Wire）吧。不会。你知道的，这只是常识。我不害怕屏幕。这是最棒的。当他们理解的时候，太棒了……但有时他们会，他们会从他们爸爸家回来
and be like, we had to watch 12 Angry Men.
And I'm like,
geez, I don't know if that's...
Well, Suds, you know.
Suds loves the 12 Angry Men.
Otis is like, oh, my God.
What are your kids, what are your go-to,
whether they're repeats,
然后说，我们不得不看《十二怒汉》（12 Aangry Men）。我说，天哪，我不知道这到底是不是……好吧，萨兹（Suds），你知道的。萨兹喜欢《十二怒汉》。奥蒂斯（Otis）就像是，哦，天哪。你的孩子们，你们的保留节目是什么，不管是重播的，
like they'll watch the same one movie over and over.
Oh, well, I miss when they were really into, like,
musical theater.
I mean, Otis used to be obsessed with singing in the rain
and it was so sweet he would watch.
watch it over and over and over again.
And, you know, Mary Poppins and all that's...
And now...
就像他们会一遍又一遍地看同一部电影。哦，好吧，我很怀念他们非常喜欢音乐剧的时候。我是说，奥蒂斯以前迷恋《雨中曲》（Singin' in the Rain），太可爱了，他会看。一遍又一遍地看。还有，你知道的，《欢乐满人间》（Mary Poppins）之类的……而现在……
Now it's more...
Actually, the thing that I love that he's into is Godzilla,
the old Godzilla's.
Oh, no, with like the claymation...
Yeah, like Mothra.
Have you seen that?
The 1960s Godzilla's are so cool and beautiful.
And he and I went to Japan a couple weeks ago
现在更多是……其实，我喜欢他迷恋的东西是《哥斯拉》，老版的《哥斯拉》。哦，不，就是那种黏土动画……对，就像摩斯拉（Mothra）。你见过吗？20世纪60年代的哥斯拉太酷、太美了。几周前他和我都去了日本
on like a little mom-son trip.
We went for a week.
I'm so jealous.
And it was the best.
It was like, it was just the greatest trip I've ever taken with another person alone.
Like it was, we laughed constantly.
And it was, it came from our shared Godzilla obsession.
Can I just say as an aside, have you guys been to Japan before, Sean?
进行了一次母子小旅行。我们去了一个星期。我太嫉妒了。这是最棒的。就像是，这是我跟另一个人独自进行过的最棒的旅行。我们一直在笑。这源于我们共同的哥斯拉痴迷。顺便说一句，你们以前去过日本吗，肖恩？
No, I want to go.
I've been a couple times as a kid.
And I have actually promised that exact trip Olivia just took to both girls individually,
just father-daughter time.
And I have not done it yet.
You got to go with Abel, the same thing.
Japan is the great.
greatest place.
没有，我想去。我小时候去过几次。我其实答应过奥利维亚（Olivia）刚刚进行的那趟旅行，要分别带两个女孩去，也就是父女专属时间。但我还没去过。你得和阿贝尔（Abel）去，一样的。日本是最棒的地方。
I couldn't love Japan anymore.
It's amazing.
And it's great for kids.
It's clean. It's so clean.
Like, Otis couldn't get over the fact that there's no trash on the street and there's no trash cans.
So it's not because, like, oh, they have so many trash cans.
It's that they just respect the city enough to not litter.
It's the everything about it is interesting and beautiful.
我对日本的爱无以复加。太棒了。而且对孩子很好。很干净。非常干净。奥蒂斯简直无法接受街上没有垃圾、也没有垃圾桶这件事。所以这并不是因为，哦，他们有那么多垃圾桶。而是因为他们足够尊重这座城市，所以不乱扔垃圾。它的方方面面都很有趣而且美丽。
And we had the best time.
We got on the bullet train.
And every, you, I bet you love it, Bateman, because.
it's very efficient.
Everything about it.
Like the train leaves like literally like to the second at the time that it says.
It's like the opposite of Italy.
Even and I love Italy too.
我们玩得最开心。我们坐了子弹头列车。而且 Bateman，我敢打赌你一定会喜欢它，因为它的效率很高。方方面面。比如火车离开的时间简直精确到秒。这简直是意大利的反面。虽然我也很喜欢意大利。
But it's like.
We went for a train.
Yeah.
It is.
And Otis is like that.
It's coming.
Yeah.
但就像是……我们去赶火车。对。确实如此。奥蒂斯就像这样：它要来了，它要来了。对。
Make a big deal.
Have a nice coffee.
One cigarette.
It's predictable.
And I think kids really like that too.
They like the idea that like it's going to happen when they say it's going to happen.
And they're just so, they're just the coolest.
Well, I saw this thing about Japan where if a kid, I may have gotten this wrong,
大惊小怪。喝杯好咖啡。抽支烟。这是可以预测的。我想孩子们也非常喜欢这一点。他们喜欢事情会按照他们说的时间发生这种概念。他们真的是，他们简直酷毙了。嗯，我看到过关于日本的一件事，如果一个孩子，我可能记错了，
if a kid is wearing yellow, then that kid is by himself and everybody watches out for that kid.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
Like the kid isn't, doesn't have a.
Unchaperone, unschapron, yeah.
Wow.
Or an orphan, perhaps.
Maybe that's an orphan uniform.
如果一个孩子戴着黄色帽子，那么那个孩子就是独自一人的，每个人都会照顾那个孩子。拜托。哦，天哪。就像那个孩子没有……没有大人陪同，没有大人陪同，对。哇。或者也许是个孤儿。也许那是孤儿制服。
Right.
Just walking around looking for a home.
This one's free.
Just grab this one if you want.
No?
I don't think so
Oh,
No, but I think I saw that
对。到处走着找个家。这个是免费的。如果你想要的话就抓这一个吧。不是吗？我不这么觉得，哦。不，但我想我看到了那个
I don't know if that's true
I don't know about that one
It's probably not
Oh hang on this is a segment we like to call it
I think I saw that
It's just really a lot of conjecture
It's next to the other segment
I think I saw that
我不知道这是否真的。我不知道那一个。可能不是。哦，等等，这是一个我们喜欢称之为“我想我看到了那个”的环节。这其实有很多猜测。它紧挨着另一个环节“我想我看到了那个”。
Scrub My Search History by Sean Hayes
Wait we have to introduce that
I may have dreamt this
All right, so here we go.
What was the thing?
What was the job?
What was the thing that turned it all?
肖恩·海耶斯的“清除我的搜索历史”等等，我们得介绍一下这个。我可能是做梦梦到这事了。好吧，我们开始吧。那是什么事？那是什么事？那是什么工作？是什么事情扭转了一切？
Because you're auditioning, you're doing so.
What was the thing?
What was the first boom?
I guess probably the OC.
The OC.
Oh, that's right.
I was a bisexual bartender, Alex Kelly.
And it was a big show.
因为你在试镜，你在做各种事情。那是什么事？第一个爆红点是什么？我想大概是《橘郡风云》（The OC）。《橘郡风云》。哦，对。我演了一个双性恋酒保，亚历克斯·凯利（Alex Kelly）。那是个很大的节目。
Bigger than I knew it was when I agreed to do it.
And it was wild.
You know, it's being rewatched now.
Oh, I know.
Because these young folks, now they come up to me and I'm like, what do you mean?
It's such a deep cut, but they will say like, I love you on the show.
And I'm like, what show?
And it's the O.C.
比我答应出演时想象的还要大。而且太疯狂了。你知道的，现在又有人在重温了。哦，我知道。因为这些年轻人，现在他们走到我面前，我就想：你在说什么？这梗太冷门了，但他们会说：我好喜欢你在剧里的表现。我就想：什么剧？就是《橘郡风云》。
And I can't believe it.
I mean, for them, it's like Nick at Night now, right?
It's like old.
I wonder why they landed on that as opposed to, let's say, 90210 or Melrose Place or...
It's close enough.
And also, they're obsessed with early aughts everything fashion now, too.
So, like, it's, it is from that era that is now weirdly coming back.
And so they're into that look and the music.
我简直不敢相信。我是说，对他们来说，现在就像是 Nick at Nite 电视台重播节目一样，对吧？就像老古董。我在想，他们为什么会选中这个，而不是比如说《飞越比弗利》（90210）或者《飞越情海》（Melrose Place）或者……这足够近了。而且，他们现在对2000年代初期的所有时尚也极其着迷。所以，它就是来自那个现在又诡异地流行起来的时代。所以他们喜欢那种造型和音乐。
It's relevant again.
Sean, you're about to be in style again.
Oh, jeez.
I mean, this is the good thing that's going to pay off.
Yeah, you're like low-rise jeans and your little crop tops.
Yeah.
It's coming back.
The thing in the mirror behind you coming up is, it's closer than it looks.
它又变得有热度了。肖恩，你马上又要引领时尚了。哦，天哪。我是说，这是将要见效的好事。对，你就像低腰牛仔裤和小短上衣。对。它卷土重来了。你身后镜子里的东西正在出现，它比看上去的要近。
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
All right, and then there was girl next door,
there was Alpha Dog, and then we got to Cowboys and Aliens.
I love that movie.
Change Up.
When are we getting to the Change Up?
I mean, were there more people that saw Cowboys and Aliens or Change Up?
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。好吧，然后有《邻家女孩》（The Girl Next Door）、《阿尔法狗》（Alpha Dog），然后我们到了《牛仔和外星人》（Cowboys & Aliens）。我喜欢那部电影。《互换身体》（The Change-Up）。我们什么时候说到《互换身体》？我是说，看《牛仔和外星人》的人多，还是看《互换身体》的人多？
Oh, that's hard.
It might have been the same five people.
Let's talk about the change up.
Let's talk about it.
Favorite memory of the change up.
My favorite memory is obviously sitting on your lap.
Poplis.
With pasties.
哦，那很难说。可能是同一拨五个人吧。我们来聊聊《互换身体》吧。我们聊聊这个。关于《互换身体》最美好的回忆。我最美好的回忆显然是坐在你的大腿上。波普利斯（Poplis）。贴着乳贴。
No, I mean from shooting.
I mean from the movie.
Oh, okay.
That was also fun.
Yeah.
That was a good time as well.
We really had the best time.
I loved making that movie.
不，我是指拍摄。我是指拍电影。哦，好吧。那也很开心。对。那段时光也很美好。我们真的度过了最棒的时光。我太喜欢拍那部电影了。
Right?
It was a blast.
Ryan's the coolest.
David Dobkin was so freaking awesome.
Oh, Dobkin.
It was really fun.
Down there in Atlanta.
I loved it.
对吧？太好玩了。瑞安太酷了。大卫·多布金超级无敌棒。哦，多布金。真的很有趣。在亚特兰大那边。我超爱。
Remember when I stopped by on the set?
At the same time, yeah, Sean, you were making three stooges at the same time.
Yes, you were.
And I walked to the mall to go see Green Lantern.
And there's Jason and Ryan filming Change Up in the middle of the mall.
Oh, wow.
And I walked right into the middle of the scene.
I was like, hey, guys.
还记得我去片场探班的时候吗？对，就在同时，肖恩，你当时在拍《三个臭皮匠》。没错，你就是在拍那个。然后我走到商场去看《绿灯侠》。杰森和瑞安正在商场中央拍《换身oring（The Change-Up）》。哦，天哪。我直接走到了拍摄现场的正中央。我说，嘿，伙计们。
Oh, they should have kept that.
Movie would have been better.
With the curly wig on?
Yeah, totally.
At the fountain.
I think it was the fountain right in the middle of the mall.
Oh, right, the fountain.
You guys were so good.
哦，他们应该把那一幕保留下来。那电影会更好看。戴着卷发头套吗？对，完全是。就在喷泉旁边。我想就是商场正中央那个喷泉。哦，对，那个喷泉。你们演得太棒了。
You were so funny together.
You got a bogey over by the fountain.
Totally.
I was shuffled along very quickly.
And then we do
Drinking Buddies, Joe Swanberg.
Yes.
That was completely improvised.
你们俩在一起太搞笑了。你在喷泉旁边惹麻烦了。确实。我很快就被轰走了。然后我们拍了《酒友行》，乔·斯旺伯格。对。那是完全即兴发挥的。
Completely improvised.
Yeah, that's like the true
Swannbergian way,
which is kind of that mumblecore,
which I think they hate that word,
mumblecore, seems very, I don't know.
It's more than it is.
It says a mumble, mumbo.
完全即兴。对，那正是斯旺伯格式的风格，有点像那种碎碎念电影（mumblecore），我觉得他们挺讨厌“碎碎念电影”这个词的，听起来好像，我不知道。这不仅仅是碎碎念，含糊不清。
I don't know.
I got a mumblecour.
It was, there's no script, there's a sort of outline,
and then you just improvise.
What is this for?
Oh, this was a movie called Drinking Buddies.
Oh, Drinky Buddies.
Isn't that similar to what they do on a curb your enthusiasm?
我不知道。我拍过碎碎念电影。那是，没有剧本，只有一个大致的大纲，然后你们就自由发挥。这是在拍什么？哦，这是一部叫《酒友行》的电影。哦，《酒友行》。这跟他们拍《抑制热情》的方法是不是有点像？
Shawnee, you've done that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it all?
So there's no written script.
No, zero.
You just got to hit the beats and then you start.
It's super fun.
It's so great.
肖妮，你拍过那个。对，对，对。完全是这样的吗？所以没有写好的剧本？没有，完全没有。你们只要把握好节奏然后就开始。超级好玩。太棒了。
And it was the first time I kind of took myself seriously
as potentially being able to write something
or maybe direct something one day
because we were really in control of the story.
And it was a collective effort.
And that workshop was so fun.
It makes it very real.
And it was, we kept learning from what happened
那是第一次我真正把自己当回事，觉得自己以后也许能写点东西或者导演点什么，因为我们确实掌控了故事。而且这是大家共同努力的结果。那个工作坊太有趣了。它让一切变得非常真实。而且，我们不断从发生的状况中学习，
and then letting that affect the next scene.
So it was like, oh, now this would happen to these people.
It was a shot in order.
We shot it mostly in order.
And that led to then the movie that I just directed,
this movie The Invite that I did completely in order.
And it was all really started in Drinking Buddies days
when I was like, this is so fun.
然后让这些影响到下一场戏。所以感觉就像是，哦，接下来这些事就会发生在这些人身上。它是按顺序拍的。我们基本上是顺着剧情顺序拍的。这就启发了我刚刚执导的电影，这部完全按顺序拍摄的电影《邀请函》。这一切其实都始于拍《酒友行》的日子，当时我就觉得，这太好玩了。
And it was a dream.
I loved making that movie.
In Chicago, drinking beer.
I love that.
So that was my next question.
So did Drinking Buddies inspire you to want to direct?
Yeah.
Is that the experience?
简直就像做梦一样。我太喜欢拍那部电影了。在芝加哥，喝着啤酒。我太喜欢了。所以这是我的下一个问题。那么，《酒友行》是不是启发了你想当导演的想法？对。就是那段经历吗？
I kind of, I wanted to do before,
but that was the first time that I was like,
wait, I think I might know how to put a scene together
because I was given the chance to sort of be a part of that process
and it was, I was like, this is the most fun.
And now having done both obviously scripted
and this version where it's improv through an outline,
do you prefer one of the other?
我以前其实就想过，但那是第一次让我觉得，等等，我想我大概知道怎么把一场戏组合起来了，因为我得到了参与那个过程的机会，当时我就觉得，这是最有趣的事。既然现在你既拍过有剧本的，也拍过这种通过大纲即兴发挥的版本，你更喜欢哪一种？
I think there's a, what I prefer is what I ended up getting to do on this movie,
which was we workshopped the script together as cast and writers.
And then we were able to shoot an order,
yeah, it was like a play.
and it was a very well-thought-out script ultimately,
but we had kind of worked it together,
and not in a full, like, Mike Lee way
where we spent like a year improvising on a cliffside
我觉得，我更喜欢的是我在这部电影里最终得以实现的方式，那就是我们作为演员和编剧一起围读并打磨剧本。然后我们能够按照剧情顺序拍摄，对，就像演话剧一样。而且它最终是一个经过深思熟虑的剧本，但我们是一起创作出来的，这不像迈克·李（Mike Lee）那种完全在悬崖边上花一年时间即兴创作的方式，
or something, it's not that.
But it was very organic because we had come,
we had really massaged it together,
and then once we got on set,
we knew exactly what we were doing.
I like that.
Well, so tell the audience a little bit more about that one.
This was called The Invite,
或者类似的东西，不是那样的。但它是非常自然的，因为我们是一起反复推敲、精雕细琢出来的，一旦到了片场，我们就确切地知道自己在做什么。我很喜欢这样。好吧，那就跟听众朋友们多聊聊那部电影吧。这部电影叫《邀请函》，
and it's inspired by or based on
It's based on a Spanish film.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So, yeah, so tell me, how did it kind of get started?
Who watched the film first?
Come on.
Who called each, who called the other person and say, you know, let's do it this way?
它是受到一部西班牙电影的启发，还是改编自……它是改编自一部西班牙电影。哦，原来如此。所以，能跟我讲讲它是怎么开始的吗？谁先看的电影？快说。是谁给谁打电话，提议说“咱们也这么拍吧”？
Okay, so Rashida Jones and Will McCormick wrote, we love, wrote the English language adaptation of a Spanish film that was called The People Upstairs.
And it was a small Spanish film that was based on a play.
that you can sort of see the origins of it as a play
because it's four people in one apartment,
and that's the whole thing takes place
with four people in one apartment over one night.
And the idea is that it's kind of a dinner party gone wrong.
It's about a husband and wife,
事情是这样的，拉什达·琼斯和威尔·麦克科米克（Will McCormick）写了，我们很喜欢，他们写了一部西班牙电影的英文改编版，那部电影叫《楼上的人》（The People Upstairs）。那是一部小成本的西班牙电影，改编自一部话剧。
in our version, it's myself and Seth Rogen,
who have been kind of plagued by the sounds
of our neighbors upstairs having very loud sex,
and it's been driving Seth's character kind of insane.
and unbeknownst to him, I've invited these people over for dinner,
and he's furious because he doesn't want to have dinner with anyone.
He's tired from work, but he says, fine, if you've ambushed me with this,
I'm going to bring up the noise from upstairs.
而且你能看出它作为话剧的起源，因为这就是四个演员在一个公寓里，整个故事就发生在这四个演员和一个公寓里，时间是一夜之间。故事的核心是一场搞砸了的晚餐派对。讲的是一对夫妻，在我们这个版本里，是我和塞斯·罗根，长期饱受楼上邻居大声做爱的噪音折磨，这快把塞斯扮演的角色逼疯了。
And I'm like, over my dead body, you'll bring up that noise.
You will not, please just try to be normal
and have a normal night so we can have friends.
And so the whole night, he's kind of threatening to bring up this thing,
and they are endlessly kind of sexy and enigmatic,
and they end up really blowing our minds
and changing our marriage in one night.
And the other couple is?
在他不知情的情况下，我把这些人请来家里吃晚饭，他气坏了，因为他根本不想跟任何人共进晚餐。他工作很累，但他还是说：“好吧，既然你搞这种突然袭击，那我就要当面提一提楼上噪音的事。”而我则态度坚决：“除非我死，否则你休想提噪音的事。绝对不行，求你了，就当是正常人一样过个正常的夜晚，好让我们能交个朋友。”所以整晚，他都在威胁说要提起这事，而那对邻居夫妇却散发着无尽的性感和神秘感，最后他们真的惊艳了我们，并在短短一个晚上彻底改变了我们的婚姻。那另一对夫妻是？
Penelope Cruz and Edward Norton.
A cast.
Unbelievable cast.
It's insane.
And so Rashida and Will wrote the English version,
and I got that script,
and I was like, this is hilarious.
And it was clearly an opportunity
佩内洛普·克鲁兹和爱德华·诺顿。这阵容。难以置信的阵容。太疯狂了。所以拉什达和威尔写了英文版，我拿到那个剧本后觉得：太搞笑了。这显然是一个机会，
to make something in this way
that I had been obsessing over since Drinking Buddies.
So I was like, okay, we can shoot this in order,
and we can really personalize this
script together and workshop it and make it really specific to these actors. And we can shoot it on 35
millimeter and we can make it really fun. And I'm obsessed with Mike Nichols. So I was like, this can be
our Virginia Woolf. And it was the best experience of my life. Sorry, Jason. And Will, we, I love
working with you guys. This one was great. But then, so you take this great script from Rashida and Will
可以用我自拍完《酒友行》以来一直魂牵梦绕的那种方式来拍一部电影。所以我想，好吧，我们可以按顺序拍摄，我们可以真正一起把这个剧本个性化，通过工作坊打磨，让它非常贴合这些演员。我们可以用35毫米胶片拍摄，我们可以把它拍得非常有趣。而且我是迈克·尼科尔斯的超级粉丝。所以我想，这可以成为我们的《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫？》。这真是我人生中最棒的经历。对不起，杰森。还有威尔，我们，我超爱跟你们合作。那部片子很棒。不过话说回来，你拿到了拉什达和威尔写得这么棒的剧本，
but then the four of you get together, the cast,
and do you guys start to take an even plus the script
because of the specificity of each actor?
Yes, and we really, the six of us sat for two weeks.
This was the thing.
I was like, can we stop giving away rehearsal time immediately
when we make movies?
Like, it's the first thing we give up.
然后你们四个演员聚在一起，你们会因为每个演员独特的个性，在剧本的基础上进行更多的创作吗？是的，我们六个人真的坐在一起围读了两周。这就是关键所在。当时我就想：我们能不能别再一拍电影就立刻砍掉排练时间了？排练总是第一个被牺牲的。
We were just talking about this recently.
Impossible to convince people.
Really agents.
Agents are the ones who are like, no, he's not available
until the minute you start rolling the camera.
And he's like, why?
Why can't we consider it part of the job?
Can you imagine doing that for theater?
我们最近刚聊过这个。根本说服不了别人。尤其是经纪人。经纪人们总是说：“不行，他直到开机那一分钟才有空。”然后就会问：“为什么？为什么我们不能把排练当成工作的一部分？”你能想象在戏剧界这样做吗？
If it was like, no, I'll be there for previews.
Then what they do is then they pro rate their salary.
They say, well, so an extra two weeks of work at this number.
Jason's also an agent.
I don't know if you knew that.
Yeah, be my agent, please.
But it really was so fun
because the six of us sat at this table
如果剧团说：“不行，我只在预演时到场。”那他们就会按比例扣减薪酬。他们会说：“好吧，那就按这个标准多支付两周的工作报酬。”杰森其实也是个经纪人。不知道你知不知道这件事。对，请当我的经纪人吧，拜托了。但那段经历真的太有趣了，我们六个人围坐在桌旁，
and we tore through the script
and Rashid and Will
were so game to
kind of let it evolve to what these actors were thinking.
God, that's fun. And it was so fun, and it was like,
imagine, I mean, Seth and Edward and Penelope
are all real filmmakers on their own.
I mean, they're directors, they're writers,
把剧本字斟句酌地啃了一遍，拉什达和威尔非常愿意让剧本顺应这些演员的想法不断演变。天哪，太有趣了。而且那种感觉妙不可言，你想想，塞斯、爱德华和佩内洛普本身就都是真正的电影人。我的意思是，他们是导演，是编剧，
and so the opportunity to kind of get all of their good ideas
and put them in there.
And Edward, Edward is on another...
First of all, Edward's maybe one of my favorite,
smartless guests.
He's, maybe that episode is really great.
I love him so much.
Well, he's so smart.
所以能够汇集他们所有的好点子并融入其中，这种机会很难得。而且爱德华，爱德华简直是另一个……首先，爱德华可能是我最喜欢的《聪明无谋》（SmartLess）嘉宾之一。他，那一期节目真的非常棒。我太喜欢他了。他太聪明了。
He's so funny.
Yeah, and he's so funny.
And people don't even,
people do know it.
But I'm obsessed with him.
And he ended up improvising
like an entire monologue
in the third act of this movie
他太搞笑了。对，他太搞笑了。大家甚至都不知道……其实大家都知道。但我对他的才华着迷不已。他最后在这部电影的第三幕里即兴发挥了一整段独白，
that is so beautiful.
And it really just,
it was his gift to us
to just kind of like,
he said to me,
I'm gonna,
I have a story I want to tell on the scene.
I kind of don't,
美极了。这真的是他送给我们的礼物，他就那样……他当时对我说：“我有一个故事，我想在这场戏里讲出来。我其实不太想提前告诉你内容是什么。”
want to tell you what it is.
And I was like, okay, yeah, how long, like, roughly?
Just because we're, like, rolling film and I was paying for the film and I was like,
just like, how, how?
Was it longer than a full mag?
I put a thousand-foot bag on the camera and I was like, go, and he used it.
And it was really great.
But it was, Penelope Cruz came up with the funniest set piece in the movie.
我就说：“好吧，行，大概多长时间？”因为我们毕竟在拍电影，而且胶片是我自掏腰包买的，我就问：“大概，大概多久？”有没有超过一整盘暗盒？我在摄影机上装了一个一千英尺的片盘，然后说：“开始吧。”他真的全用上了。效果真的棒极了。不过，佩内洛普·克鲁兹想出了电影里最好笑的一个桥段。
And it was all with the, you know, workshopping with Rashida and Will who would,
man, just like run with the punches of roll or run?
Do you roll or you roll with them?
You don't roll with the punch, yeah.
They roll and ran.
They ran with the ball.
It was the best.
这一切都多亏了与拉什达和威尔的工作坊讨论，他们总是能，天哪，顺着罗尔（Roll）或者……是罗尔还是跑？你是叫滚还是跑？你不是“顺着拳头”（roll with the punch）吗，对。他们顺应并展开了。他们接住了这个梗并发挥得淋漓尽致。太棒了。
And then I wasn't supposed to be in the movie,
but the actors bullied me into playing that part,
which was very sweet of them.
Well, now, how do you find that?
Do you find it efficient to direct yourself,
or do you find it distracting?
I think in this case it was efficient
because it was so intimate.
然后我本来不打算演这部电影的，但演员们“霸凌”我让我演那个角色，他们人真的太好了。那么，你觉得怎么样？你觉得自导自演有效率，还是觉得会分心？我觉得在这个案子里挺高效的，因为剧组规模很亲密。
It was almost like having one less body on set
was actually really helpful.
And I think that it allowed me to see things they were all doing.
These geniuses were doing so many little things
that I could see things the camera couldn't see.
And so I'd be like, oh, okay, now we need to come around
because Seth is doing something that I actually need us to get.
And so in that way, it was good.
片场少了一个人，感觉实际上非常有用。而且我觉得这让我能够观察到他们所有人都在做的事。这些天才们做了那么多微小的细节表演，我能捕捉到摄影机捕捉不到的东西。所以我会想：“哦，好吧，现在我们要绕过来了，因为塞斯在做一个我必须拍下来的动作。”从这个角度来看，这样很好。
I feel like it could be very difficult in a different situation.
I also was playing someone who was, like, riddled with anxiety,
which helped.
because I could just kind of be me.
Were they comfortable with you directing them inside a take,
or did you have to wait until you yelled cut before you gave them notes?
I wasn't, I didn't do a like, okay, give me a little more, give me a little, like in this,
still rolling, I'm still rolling, I want more, go deeper.
我觉得在其他不同情况下，这可能会非常困难。而且我演的角色本身就焦虑缠身，这倒帮了忙，因为我只要做自己就行了。对于你在实拍过程中直接对他们进行导演指导，他们习惯吗？还是说你必须等喊了“咔”之后再给他们提意见？我没有那种——“好，再多给我一点情绪，再多给我一点”——在实拍时，还在拍着呢，我还开着机，我就说：“我要更多，挖得更深。”
I didn't do that at all.
In character, directed in character.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I really believe in letting people kind of play and try things,
and then knowing that what I,
really can do as a director is later on prune and adjust things in the edit.
So I just think it was encouraging them to keep experimenting.
And with Seth, I would have to tell him he could be meaner to me because our characters,
我完全没有这么做。我是以角色的身份在戏里进行指导的。对，对。不，我真的很相信让演员去尽情玩耍、尝试各种可能，然后作为导演，我真正能做的是在后期的剪辑中进行修剪和调整。所以我只是在不断鼓励他们继续实验。至于塞斯，我有时不得不告诉他，他对我可以再凶狠一点，因为我们饰演的角色，
it's a very contentious relationship and there's a lot of arguing.
And he's a very non-confrontational person.
So the most direction I gave Seth was like, you can fucking scream at me.
Like I can take it.
And angry Seth is a thing to behold.
Because he's got it in him.
It turns out.
How many days was it then?
关系非常紧张，有很多争吵。而他本人是一个很不愿起冲突的人。所以我给塞斯最多的指导就是：“你可以冲我大吼大叫。我承受得起。”而且发火的塞斯绝对是一大奇观。因为他骨子里有这个爆发力。事实证明确实如此。那总共拍了多少天？
It must have been.
23.
Amazing.
Yeah, so fast.
Wow.
And like just the best.
I mean, we were on this little soundstage,
Sunset Las Palmas.
肯定很……23天。太惊人了。对，超级快。哇。而且简直是最棒的体验。我们在日落拉斯帕尔马斯（Sunset Las Palmas）的一个小摄影棚里拍的。
It's the pink one.
If you remember the opening of the player
when he drives in, it's that.
And it's iconic.
It's great and tiny.
And we were all, we built the set on stage
and we just, you know, banged it out.
And then a year later went to Sundance.
就是那个粉红色的。如果你还记得《大玩家》（The Player）开场他开车进去的那个地方，就是那里。非常标志性。又棒又小。我们在摄影棚里搭了景，然后大家齐心协力，就把片子赶出来了。一年后我们就去了圣丹斯电影节。
It was so fast.
We get in the weeds for one.
One second.
Did you have multiple cameras?
Oh.
We had one camera.
No.
And then towards the last week, we brought in a second camera because we wanted to just be able to,
太快了。我们先纠结一个细节。等一下。你们当时用的是多台摄影机吗？噢。我们只有一台摄影机。没有。然后到了最后一周，我们引入了第二台摄影机，因为我们希望能够，
there were some scenes that they benefited from two cameras.
But I didn't want to.
I felt like I had been inspired by like Tarantino saying, like, don't be a hack.
Have one camera.
Pick your perspective.
Anytime you have two cameras, one shot is suffering.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
Well, but you've got these four people talking all the time,
有些场景用两台摄影机拍摄会更有优势。但我不想这样做。我觉得我是受到昆汀的话的启发，他说过：“别当个庸才。用一台摄影机。选定你的视角。任何时候只要你用了两台摄影机，其中一个镜头就会受损。”当时我就觉得，哦，这太酷了。但是，你们有四个角色一直在说话，
and so you've got to do it four times at least
so that everyone gets a camera pointed at them.
Yes.
We did a lot of shared frame.
That's why it is very theatrical in that way
that there's a lot of times we're sharing the frame,
which is why we had the best focus puller in the world
who could somehow predict when someone was going to improvise a joke.
所以你们至少得拍四遍，好让每个人的脸上都对准摄影机。是的。我们拍了很多同框镜头。正因如此，它在形式上非常具有舞台感，很多时候我们都在同一个画幅里，这也是为什么我们拥有世界上最厉害的焦点员，他居然能不知怎么地预判到什么时候有人会即兴抖出一个包袱。
And it's also better, I think, for comedy
because there's nothing worse than cutting back
between, you know, from singles in comedy.
love seeing people inhabiting the same frame in a comic.
Oh, it's so thrilling because they really did that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's so much better.
So if you take a left on Las Palma, it's like street parking, obviously,
而且我觉得这对于喜剧效果更好，因为没有什么比在喜剧里频繁在单人特写镜头之间切来切去更糟糕的了。我喜欢看喜剧演员们出现在同一个画幅里。哦，太让人激动的，因为他们确实做到了。对，对，对，对。这样好太多了。所以如果你在拉斯帕尔马斯街（Las Palma）向左拐，那里是可以路边停车的，
again, Jason, I know that you want.
Where'd the trucks go?
Also, editing comedy, too, I just find, I always think, you know,
I gave you or whoever it is, they gave you the comedy timing
while you were filming it.
And the editor plays with it.
It's like, no, we gave you.
the timing when we were filming it.
再说一次，杰森，我知道你想……运货车都去哪了？另外，剪辑喜剧其实我也发现，我总是觉得，我给了你或者不管是谁，你在拍的时候就已经把喜剧节奏把握好了，剪辑师只是在玩弄它。其实不对，是我们拍的时候就已经把节奏给你们了。
Yes.
That's what it is.
Exactly.
It's a tough thing to maintain.
Yeah.
God.
It's why Wonders are so good.
Exactly.
没错。就是这样。要保持这一点很难。天哪。怪不得《神奇女侠》那么棒。没错。
Because they're just fully intact.
But you had so much
technique and know-how
and execution
right out of the gate with Booksmart
was like,
just like a stunning accomplishment.
That must have felt so good.
因为它们非常完整。但你在处女作《高材生》中一出手就展现了如此多的技巧、专业知识和完美的执行力，简直是一项惊人的成就。当时感觉一定棒极了。
The movie's so good.
That was your first movie you directed?
Yeah.
It's insane.
I think that,
It really was because my proxy film school,
because I didn't go to college,
那部电影太棒了。那是你执导的第一部电影？对。太疯狂了。简直疯狂。我觉得，这确实是因为那是我的“代用电影学院”，因为我没上过大学，
didn't go to film school,
and I was always insecure about that lack of education.
And I think that being on so many sets as an actor,
I just paid attention to everything,
and I just tried to absorb it.
But yeah, I think Booksmart,
I think often your first movie is the one you've been building up
for your entire life,
没上过电影学院，我一直对缺乏这种教育背景感到有些不自信。我觉得作为演员在那么多片场待过，我只是注意观察了一切，然后尽量去吸收。但对吧，我觉得《高材生》往往是那种你为之准备了一辈子的电影，
and you put all of your ideas into it,
and you have so much to give.
and you're lucky if it resonates with people.
And I got so lucky because it happened to hit, you know,
a place in a lot of people's kind of shared trauma of adolescence.
Like, that's the thing I love about high school movies.
But even just the making of it, Olivia, like, you know,
and the stuff that you wouldn't have been around to observe
你把自己所有的想法都倾注其中，你有那么多东西想要表达，如果它能引发观众的共鸣，那你就算是很幸运了。我真的很幸运，因为它恰好击中了很多人青春期共同创伤的某个痛点。这就是我喜欢高中电影的原因。但仅仅是拍摄的过程本身，奥利维亚，你知道的，有些东西是你作为一个演员在旁边观察不到的，
and to sort of cherry-pick from these great directors,
all this post-incredbleness in that film.
the editing style, the choice and the use of music and stuff like,
that's all shit that people usually need like a handful of movies under their belt
before they really kind of, I don't know, I just was so happy.
Again, the science of it is you're born with it, you're born with it.
Yeah, we're going to cut you open and take a look.
Yeah, get in there.
也无法从那些伟大导演身上轻易借鉴的，比如那部电影里所有后期制作的高超技巧，剪辑风格、音乐的选择与运用等等，这些通常都是导演需要拍过好几部电影之后才能真正……我不知道，我当时太开心了。再说一次，这门科学就是天生的，你生来就会。对，我们要剖开你的肚子看一看。对，钻研进去。
I love it.
I'm a much better director than actor, but I love acting too, but directing,
I do.
Guys, tell me, am I wrong?
Are you?
No, you're right.
No, I just love it.
You paused after you said that.
我太喜欢了。我当导演比当演员好得多，虽然我也很爱演戏，但我确实更爱导演。伙计们，告诉我，我没说错吧？对不对？不，你没说错。不，我只是太爱了。你刚说完那句话之后停顿了一下。
I did.
I was like, uh.
So, Olivia, what, what's going on when you're not working?
Pickleball or what?
Oh, no.
Should I learn it?
Fuck.
No.
我是。我当时想，呃。奥利维亚，你，不工作的时候在干嘛？打匹克球还是别的什么？哦，不。我应该学吗？靠。不。
I was in Central Park the other day and they were playing it.
And someone was playing like Jimmy Hendrix, the stereo and like, everybody was playing
pickleball.
And I was like, what a beautiful hobby that I don't do.
But I like to watch.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What is the hobby someone would be?
前几天我在中央公园，看到他们在那儿玩。有人在音响里放着吉米·亨德里克斯的歌，所有人都在打匹克球。我就想，这是一项多么美好的爱好啊，虽然我不玩。但我喜欢看。对。我不知道。有什么爱好是别人会
surprise to learn that you've got.
It's just us.
No one's listening.
No, it's just us.
Between us, gals.
Yeah, or the pastime,
or like the guilty TV or the thing.
Do you have a thing that you do?
知道你有，可能会觉得惊讶的？只有我们。没人听。不，只有我们。咱们姐妹之间。对，或者是消遣，或者像那种看不够的肥皂剧或者别的什么。你有什么常做的事吗？
You're like, oh my God,
I can't believe I'm wasting my time doing this.
I don't really.
I mean, hobbies, yeah.
I mean, I feel like I'm really recently,
it's like I'm working or I'm mothering.
Yeah.
And.
你会觉得，天哪，我真不敢相信自己居然把时间浪费在这上面。我其实没有。我是说，爱好，有。我是说，我觉得最近，要么就是在工作，要么就是在带娃。对。然后。
What's the dumbest thing that you do?
Because like, you know, the directing is like,
you can't stop thinking because you,
there's never,
right.
You've never have it all figured out.
So, like, what do you do that requires zero thinking?
Do you ever just stare at the television and let it just talk to you?
你做过最蠢的事是什么？因为，你知道，当导演就像是，你的大脑根本停不下来，因为你，永远没有，对吧。你永远无法把所有事情都想得十全十美。所以，你做什么事是完全不用动脑子的？你有没有过只是盯着电视发呆，任由它对你唠叨？
Yeah.
Yeah, I love.
Will you get wrapped up in crap?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I just watched Love is Blind.
Oh, God, it's great.
So good.
对。对，我喜欢。你会陷进那些垃圾节目里吗？对。哦，会。我刚看了《爱情盲约》。哦，天哪，太棒了。太精彩了。
I did four hours of below deck yesterday.
You did?
I did four full hours of below deck yesterday.
I did a 90-day fiancé before the 90 days.
Oh, oh.
I've done a bunch of episodes.
Wow.
我昨天刷了四个小时的《下层航海》。真的吗？我昨天整整刷了四个小时的《下层航海》。我看了一部《90天婚介：远隔重洋》。哦，哦。我看了一堆集数。哇。哇。
Olivia, any reality?
I mean, I love love on the spectrum.
That makes me cry, and I love it so much.
Incredible.
And, no, I mean, I love a housewife.
But I think that for me, it's like...
Oh, any city on housewives.
I mean, I like Beverly Hills, but I think that any city will do it for me.
奥利维亚，你看真人秀吗？我是说，我喜欢《纯真爱恋》。那节目让我落泪，我太喜欢了。太不可思议了。而且，不，我是说，我喜欢《娇妻》系列。但我觉得对我来说，就像是……哦，《娇妻》的任何城市我都行。我是说，我喜欢比弗利山庄，但我觉得哪个城市的我都行。
Yeah.
But I think that, like, I just watched all of love story, and I got really into it.
It's not, that's the Ryan Murphy.
That's the...
Carolyn Bassett.
Right, right, right, right.
Got really into that.
And it's not quite reality TV,
对。但我觉得，就像我刚看完美剧《美国爱情故事》，我完全迷上了。不是，那是瑞恩·墨菲的作品。那是……卡罗琳·贝塞特。对，对，对，对。完全迷上那个了。虽然这不算真正意义上的真人秀，
but you still feel like a little,
there's something a little guilty pleasure about it.
I haven't watched that,
but the only bummer about that love story to me is that it's made.
They die in the end?
No, it's made Odeon really busy again in Tribeca.
Oh, my God, that's true.
I'm like, oh, all these people are coming.
但你还是会觉得有点，带有一点点罪恶的快感。我还没看过，但那个爱情故事唯一让我觉得扫兴的是，它被拍成了……他们在最后死了吗？不，它让翠贝卡的欧登餐厅又变得超级火爆。哦，天哪，确实。我就想，哦，所有这些人都涌过来了。
What that's cool?
Oh, get out of here.
Oh, that's the restaurant we ate at.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Before we let you go, because we're coming up on the end here.
It's so fast.
This is crazy.
这有什么酷的？哦，得了吧。哦，那就是我们吃饭的那家餐厅。对，对，对。对。在我们让你离开之前，因为节目快结束了。时间过得太快了。这太疯狂了。
Holy shit.
Talk to us about another new thing coming up called I Want Your Sex.
I do.
I want your sex.
Right?
All right.
It is.
Got our clip.
操。跟我们聊聊另一部即将上映的新片，叫《我要你的性》。对。我想要你的性。对吧？没错。就是它。我们有片花。
That is, I want it.
That is Greg Araki, who is a real, like, very cool filmmaker, who is a real L.A.
filmmaker.
He is an autort.
And wild.
I mean, very, very much an individual.
And I play a dominatrix.
And, of course.
那是，我想要。那是格雷格·阿拉基，他是一位真正的、非常酷的电影人，一位真正的洛杉矶电影人。他是一个有作者风格的导演。而且很疯狂。我是说，非常非常有个人风格。我在里面扮演一个施虐女王。当然。
And I get to...
Who are you dominating?
You're dominating the sweet little Cooper Hoffman.
You know, he doesn't deserve to get whipped.
He loved it.
And it is a very, very campy fun movie.
And it was really cool because when we were at Sundance with the invite,
I Want Your Sex premiered on Friday, and the invite was Saturday.
而且我有机会……你在虐谁？你在虐那个可爱的甜心库珀·霍夫曼。你知道的，他不配挨鞭子。他可喜欢了。这是一部非常非常具有坎普风格、很有趣的电影。而且真的很酷，因为我们在圣丹斯电影节收到邀请时，《我要你的性》在周五首映，而《邀请函》是在周六。
and I just felt so lucky to be able to be a part of this fun business
where we get to tell all these crazy stories
and they both got bought magically and so and they're coming out right after each other
and it's so fun yeah it's like invite in them out so I want your sex comes out July 23rd
which is in about 10 days from this air date here and the invite is out
invites already out.
Yeah, it came out June 26.
June 26, New York.
我真的觉得自己太幸运了，能成为这个有趣行业的一部分，我们能讲述所有这些疯狂的故事，而且两部电影都神奇地被买下了，它们将相继上映，真的太有趣了，对，就像是邀请函和它们上映一样，所以《我要你的性》将于7月23日上映，距离今天的播出日期大约还有10天，而《邀请函》已经上映了，邀请函已经上映了。对，它在6月26日上映。6月26日，在纽约。
You're not on my birthday, guys.
Now you have plans.
No, we have plans.
I mean, you did plans.
We saw it.
Yeah, on my birthday.
That was my birthday.
And you had the best time
你们不是在我生日那天，伙计们。现在你们有计划了。不，我们有计划。我是说，你确实有计划。我们看过了。对，在我生日那天。那是我的生日。而且你们玩得最开心
and everyone laughed so hard.
Yes, I loved it.
Oh, I'm glad you loved it.
Your favorite film, come on.
Of all time?
You liked the beginning and you loved the middle
but you really was the end.
She shed a tear.
每个人都笑得前仰后合。是的，我很喜欢。哦，我很高兴你喜欢。你最喜欢的电影，得了吧。有史以来最喜欢的？你喜欢开头，也喜欢中间，但你真正喜欢的是结尾。她流了一滴眼泪。
Yeah.
I walked out and not dry.
And then we're going to all look forward to the behemoth with sweet, sweet Willie Arnett,
coming out sometime next year, right?
At some point.
Meanwhile, you're probably hard at work, getting ready to direct your next incredible movie.
We're all waiting for it.
Please be in it.
对。我走出去的时候眼睛都是湿的。然后我们都要期待那部由甜蜜的威利·阿内特主演的巨制了，明年某个时候上映，对吧？在某个时候。同时，你可能也在努力工作，准备导演你的下一部精彩电影。我们都在等着呢。请让我演个角色吧。
You're the best.
Can you just give us a hint of what you're working on in an area or no?
It's a comedy.
It's a Christmas comedy.
I'm in.
I'm already in.
I love a Christmas comedy.
You should see Sean play an elf.
你太棒了。你能稍微透露一下你正在筹备的领域是什么吗，还是不能说？是一部喜剧。是一部圣诞喜剧。我演。我直接加入。我太喜欢圣诞喜剧了。你应该看看肖恩演的小精灵。
He did it with Kenny Rogers.
He was on the road with Kenny Rogers.
Yeah.
Please come be in a self-tape over with real good lighting.
Yes.
I'll actually put myself in a winter wonderland just so you really get it.
Yeah, yeah.
Great.
他跟肯尼·罗杰斯一起演过。他跟肯尼·罗杰斯一起巡演过。对。请让我来录个自拍试镜吧，光线一定要调得特别好。好。我甚至会把自己P进一个冰雪奇境里，好让你真切感受到那种氛围。对，对。太棒了。
What was your line?
Santa, I don't know when to hold them or when to fold them.
Fold them.
That's what it was.
We love you, Olivia.
I love you guys.
Thank you for having me.
你的台词是什么？圣诞老人，我不知道什么时候该亮出底牌，什么时候该放弃。放弃。就是这句。就是这句。我们爱你，奥利维亚。我也爱你们。谢谢你们邀请我。
What a dream.
And congrats on everything.
Yeah, super, super congrats.
Thank you.
Keep going.
girl. Thanks.
Bye.
简直像做梦一样。祝贺你的一切。对，超级超级祝贺。谢谢。加油。女孩。谢谢。拜拜。拜拜。
See you soon.
Bye.
Wow.
拜拜。回头见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。哇。
That's the incredibly charming.
Olivia Wilde.
Love her.
You can tell she's funny.
She's super funny.
Super funny.
这就是极具魅力的奥利维亚·王尔德。太喜欢她了。太喜欢她了。你能看出她很有趣。她超级有趣。她超级有趣。超级有趣。
So smart.
So, so smart.
And so cool.
I'm just so excited that she's directing and that it's just like,
she could like just do it forever, you know?
But, like, she's incredible out.
She's got every gear.
太聪明了。太，太聪明了。而且太酷了。我真的好激动她能执导电影，而且感觉就像，她可以一直拍下去，你知道吗？而且，她真的是个全能人才。她什么都能驾驭。她什么都能驾驭。
She's got a director, actor.
And they're all working.
I know.
They're all working, yeah.
All the gear.
I'd love to have a gear.
她什么都能驾驭。她是导演，是演员。而且都在发光发热。我知道。都在发光发热，对。我知道。全能。我也想拥有一项全能。
It would be nice.
A gear.
She's got it all.
You know?
What are you doing?
What are you doing with your life?
Well, I don't know.
I tell you what I am doing on October 17th.
那一定很棒。全能。她什么都会。你知道吗？你在干嘛？你这辈子都在干嘛？好吧，我不知道。我告诉你我10月17日要干嘛。
What do you, what's that?
Well, if you go to smartless.com slash live, you'll find out what I'm doing.
And it has to do with the Hollywood Bowl.
I'll just say that.
Oh, what's happening?
What's happening?
that smartless.com slash live has to do with the Hollywood Bowl.
What do you mean?
你要干嘛，那是什么？如果你访问 smartless.com 斜杠 live，你就会知道我在干嘛。这和好莱坞碗剧场有关。我只能说这么多了。哦，要发生什么？要发生什么？smartless.com 斜杠 live 和好莱坞碗剧场有关。什么意思？
And you know what?
I'm going to invite you guys.
What?
Join me.
I'm available.
Yeah.
What are we going to be doing?
We're going to do a live smartless show at the Hollywood Bowl.
你知道吗？我要邀请你们。什么？加入我。我有空。对。我们要干嘛？我们要在好莱坞碗剧场举办一场现场版 Smartless 节目。
Smartless.com slash live on October 17th.
It's going to be.
So it's going to be off the...
Fwp, Fwap.
Hollywood Bowl.
Oh, wow.
Listen, what we're going to do is we're going to, you know, the New York's got the...
Okay, here we go.
10月17日，访问 Smartless.com 斜杠 live。这将是……太棒了。好莱坞碗剧场。哦，哇。听着，我们要做的就是，你知道，纽约有个……好吧，我们开始吧。
Finally, Jason's got one.
New York's got the apple.
L.A.'s got the orange.
And so what we're going to do is since, you know, the Hollywood Bowl is such a big part of L.A.,
we're going to go ahead and take a big...
Out of the orange, we're going to take a big bite.
The worst ever.
Smart.
杰森总算想出一个了。纽约有个大苹果。洛杉矶有个大橙子。所以我们要做的就是，既然好莱坞碗剧场对洛杉矶来说这么重要，我们要直接去咬……从橙子上，我们要狠狠咬上一大口。史上最烂。聪明。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.
Smartless 由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%有机手工打造。Smartless。